drift people the thing is stickers
unfortunately one of them i stuck on i
didn't read what it said
and it said something like that like
oh my god can i translate that first
hello and welcome to another episode of
trash taste i am your host for today
the host zone because well i'll get to
that because with me today is
again the boys and once again
i have another guest with me
just we should just like preface that
like every time god's a host
just prepare for a guest at this point
oh my god so do do you want to introduce
yourself to the lovely viewers
okay um hello my name is alexi smith
from the youtube channel noriarro
here's the drift guy yeah yeah i'm well
one of
the drift guys i thought i'd uh reach
out to you after your recent video and
uh
thank you yeah so for anyone who doesn't
know what you do do you want to
introduce your channel and
kind of what you do on your channel okay
well it's basically
uh about car culture and drifting in
japan you know it's uh
people know tokyo drift and stuff like
that but initial d
are the two main things right uh you
know people cars are popular all over
the world and japanese cars are popular
everywhere and
this is where they're from and i enjoy
them so i came here to do it nice nice
yeah i think uh because you reached out
to us
i think like a month ago or something
yeah well you obviously because now
you're the huge caliber guest that you
could actually
get on this show uh unavailable i guess
they can't come from overseas yeah
so i thought okay well i mean i'm here i
might as well reach out because you know
now's my time this is my one chance to
do this
because you know i know i know about
cars which you've done a little bit of
and also yeah you know this sort of
culture until i really enjoyed anime and
not gonna lie when you did reach out to
us like i think because we saw your
twitter post
uh i think what was it like maybe a week
it was
so we we recorded our drift video in the
middle of the week i believe
yeah um and then you were the weekend
right after we recorded and we were like
god damn it man we we were we were just
there
i felt bad and i like i knew i knew as
soon as we saw like that twitter and we
were having this video in production
that like the top some of the some of
the top comments would be why didn't you
why didn't you enjoy
one opportunity and you messed it up
well here you go guys here you go
look i knew that we have a lot of
crossover
yeah viewers and i knew that at least a
lot of them would
enjoy that and it could add something
extra to the content you already did so
that's why i reached out yeah yeah
perfect yeah well thank you very much
for coming on the podcast thank you
and uh we now have an actual like
someone who experienced in drifting
rather than just three idiots
who are trying to drive manual for the
first time well two of us trying to
drive manual
yeah and uh i would like to set the
story straight gentlemen
um go on all the comments clowned on me
said that i broke two cars
and we have a guest here who's an expert
and actually you know the guy right the
what was his name because we didn't
actually get it oh you didn't actually
um okay so the guy
that took you for a ride right right the
big orange car with the carbon fiber
helmet
the drip well his name is
and he's one of the two members of one
of many a few members of team
orange which is why the car was orange
right right team orange is the
team which is based at episode circuit
the leader of the team is also the
manager of the circuit as well
right and now tsunaga is one of the
drivers uh for competition and also
another guy who drives
with him as well and they're both doing
i think the two team orange drivers one
of them is currently in first place
in the the national drifting competition
and i think soon argus about
fifth so you what you're with one of the
best drivers
yeah because arguably in the world yeah
because i remember we got a lot of
comments on that video being like
did they not realize who the drift
killed actually
it was two comments it was like do they
not realize the cars that you're
drifting in as well
which were apparently some very special
cars i like we we knew nothing going
into this
i'll get the one with the spoiler all
the car enthusiasts
the so the guy anyway so the guy you got
uh naoto uh he's a really cool guy like
you noticed that he was like laughing
and smiling
yeah yeah yeah he's actually like that
all the time like he's whenever
yeah yeah he's actually uh one of the
videos on my channel uh
it's called a high-speed violent drift
which is based around entirely his
driving i mean that's the best way to
explain what we wear
yeah he's very he's very quick he's very
good like the way it's like watching
bruce lee like yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah he's not and
and you told me that he you were texting
him right
because i just just before yeah right
right and you asked him what i'd done to
the cars
yeah do you want to explain to the
audience sorry so i can be
uh cleansed of my sins indicated
okay so breaking a car in drifting is
not uncommon it's obviously
that's what i figured right yeah it
feels like
yeah yeah you know doing what you do in
a drift car is almost the exact opposite
of what people tell you to do to a car
to begin with yeah and
i think what happened with you was with
the first car which was uh
an r33 skyline is that special uh it's
well i mean look okay all the cars that
you drove are not available
uh in any other country apart from japan
oh like originally being sold yeah
because yeah i saw a lot of comments
that were they were jealous that we were
able to drive these cars and i
like i i didn't know what was so special
about them well the skyline
people know the skyline the skyline gtl
it's like sort of the apex
you know japanese sports car that people
want to get uh so there's that
you didn't have the gti you had the gtst
it's like one step down but it's
rear-wheel drive that's right
uh the other cars that you drove were a
uh um they were both
uh jcx 90 mark ii and jsx 100 mark
ii right and that's okay sorry
some people people know what i'm talking
about so the the what makes those cars
special is
uh the fact that they're turbo rear
wheel drive they suit
which means the rear wheels spin instead
of the front wheels right it's good for
drifting
and what uh those cars become very
popular recently especially overseas
because uh like i said they weren't sold
overseas but in countries like america
they can import cars that are up to
over 25 years old right right and those
guys are just coming up to 25 years old
now
so everyone's like oh i want to get one
of these you know
you noticed that the toyotas were the
last to break right
the nissan broke first toyota's uh you
know anyone who's driven a
a camry or anything like that will know
like they just last forever
yeah so they're popular uh people are
looking forward to getting them so
that's
why people were hyped i actually drive
one the same as the the who drove the
white car that was you
i got i drove i my my off car is the
same as that the one that didn't break
yeah the one that's
the one the only one that lasted what
was the diagnosis
to the cars that i drove so naga said
that you
probably broke a coil pack okay which is
uh it's like part of the electronics on
this which is what they said battery
right
it's part of the the electronics it sits
on the engine and makes the spark that
burns the fuel yeah
right right so normally when you drive a
car you're driving forward and you're
not doing burnouts and spinning the
wheels yeah
stopping making a lot of heat and stuff
like that so that day was very hot
you probably overheated the coil pack so
it sits on top of the engine which is
hot
and okay obviously i'm liking the sound
it just got a bit it got a bit too hot
and had to take a lie down for a while
yeah so nothing serious nothing serious
i thought i [ __ ] the clutch or
something but i don't know if that's it
it sounded like it it made like the
worst
sound i'd ever heard it was like a car i
mean they those cars make weird noises
like honestly like if you the first time
if you drive like if i jump in someone
else's drift car and like just even
drive it around
yeah uh you have to spend the first five
minutes going okay that's a normal noise
that's
figuring out which voices are yeah if
usually the way it works is if
if something smells different or sounds
dramatically different
then you probably have a problem after
that yeah because
i remember when we first got into the
cars for the first time i mean they were
stripped bare i'd never been in a car
like that that was just
specifically designed for one purpose
and that was for drifting you know and
it was
it felt like when i was turning on the
engine it was like coughing i was like
and i was like is is this normal but it
sounded like and it felt like these cars
had been
gone through a hell of a beating which
is what they kind of they asked them
for the school uh for the team orange
school which is what you did
um i've actually in the in the past been
an assistant teacher like a translator
for
uh like the yeah in english for the like
the highest some of the higher level
oh yeah this is a while ago like we had
a guy who was like um
uh investment banker for barclays bank
or something like that
you know he had like uh he had ferraris
back home in england and before he was
being sent back home
you know back to his home office from
the japan office yeah uh
he'd been asked by his secretary is
there anything he'd like to do
you know before you know with something
we'd like to
so they set all this up and they you
know they sent him there on the train
i'd go pick him up
yeah i was like oh this is like super
high level guest and and he thoroughly
enjoyed it so
we have all sorts of people and so those
cars have been through a lot of
i i figured that those cars were they
were a car
but i i just assumed they were all bits
and pieces that have been repaired and
repaired and repaired right like
can you even call it the car at that
point right isn't that like a philosophy
question where it's like if you're a
farmer's axe or yeah
at least the skyline i've seen it
personally go through two clutches
before so
i mean when they even opened the thing
all of the parts looked like
like completely different ages like you
it
it's a piece of work i guess yeah i mean
those cars are all
unfortunately all the best drift cars
are starting to get quite old like
they're right like 20 30 years ago
and uh you know you have to start taking
you have like
some people will buy if they have space
you'll buy like two or three of these
cars you have them at the back
something breaks you take a part or you
smash it you cut off the metal and weld
it onto the
car and right fix it so yeah they're all
like that it's it's uh it's unique you
can't
you can't love a drift car you can love
like the
you can have like it it's kind of
esoteric but a drift car will have its
own
spirit right but it's not related to the
body of the car it's
the ghost of the drift you might have to
change the engine you have to change
this
yeah it's basically all parts getting
changed yeah so that's one call that i
[ __ ] but it wasn't my fault in the end
thank you thank you yeah we should
second card
what was the second card he didn't get
back to me about that
i don't know so he probably did [ __ ]
back up but you gave me a theory
off the podcast saying that he reckons
it's all the stalling that somebody did
to it that might have [ __ ] it
so on uh please tell please tell i'm
pleased
i'm assuming that you didn't you edited
out like most of the stalling you did
it's like there's a lot more than what
actually yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah i stole the la video
but that was probably maybe like a third
of the amount that i mean
we could probably make a like an hour
special just on or just just on joey's
stalling
by himself but probably to explain to
our audio only listeners
that probably didn't see the drifting
video so we made a drift special
you should definitely go watch get off
get off whatever platform you are go go
on youtube get on youtube
um and yeah we made a drift special
where we
tried to learn drifting for the first
time
ever basically this is our first
underlying bold letters
yeah right and uh i didn't break two
cars
you absolutely broke two cars but but i
guess for like for our listeners who
know nothing about drifting no nothing
about car culture do you want to explain
like what drift culture is
especially in japan from like in like
layman's terms okay well
drifting is uh if you've never done it
before
is uh like most people who have driven a
car well these days like cars have a lot
of safety features on them like
right they have anti-lock brakes and
stability control and all this sort of
stuff which
sort of you know protects you a little
bit from making too much of a mistake
yeah but everybody who has lived
somewhere it rains a lot or it snows or
something like that
has had a moment where you've gone
around a corner or like a roundabout or
something
where the car is just sort of going like
this yeah or like that you're like
yeah you get that crunch in your stomach
you're like oh that's not right
yeah that's the feeling we're going for
the whole
the the the feeling of like the out of i
mean i think they said that
in um tokyo drive it's like you've got
to be out of control to be in control
it's that
it's like you know surfing or skiing
it's like you're
not you're not gripping what you're on
you're sliding across it
and it's that being on the razor edge of
that of that slide
which is just so much fun not everybody
thinks it's fun
some people do i mean same thing like i
mean some people love surfing
some people love skiing or ice skating
or whatever any of those sorts of things
where it's like something
like that you know you can enjoy it like
that's not for me but then some people
just get a massive
rush yeah it was it was a lot of fun i
remember
experiencing the drift taxi for the
first time i remember having a
conversation with joey which we didn't
record but joey was telling me how
it felt like the afterglow after sex is
what you described as
i was like i was metaphorically
rock-hard
i was like damn dude i was like damn how
am i ever going to get an erection again
some of the most in i mean some of the
most uh chill i've ever been in my life
was you know
driving back from a track day yeah which
was so nice
like yeah nine o'clock at night on the
expressway just cruising along going
back home it's like you know cool breeze
and it's just like
you get a every every every single you
know organ in your body which can
release some sort of chemical
enjoyment chemical yeah it does that it
honestly does that like
i've had times where like when i when i
first moved here and i
remember i bought the car i did this
stuff finally got to track day
and this one particular corner i hit it
it was a big long third geek corner
and i literally yelled out this is why i
came to japan
it was that feeling it was like i was
looking for that like yeah yeah he found
his life purpose going around the corner
wow yeah it's it's just really enjoyable
one thing i wondered when i was doing it
i was like how the [ __ ] do you get into
this
that's what i was gonna ask you as well
you know like like you said like skiing
and stuff like that even that is like
i think a lot of people think skiing is
kind of hard to get into a snowboarding
it's not really you just
go to a mountain you do the weekend just
try it out and you get into it right
it's not that difficult but with a
with drifting uh it seems like there's a
lot more commitment and also it's just
way harder to get into like because when
we try to do the drifting video
they initially wanted us to buy a car
yeah we were like well
the [ __ ] we're going to do with the car
after we're done right there we can sell
it back i'm like i don't want to [ __ ]
go through that that sounds like a pain
but yeah
you know even you can rent skis right
you can rent snowboards
how do you take that first leap to
getting into drifting
and also especially if you have no
background because those people at the
track
like the kids who've worked there i mean
they're like 17 teaching yeah
insane but you know they've obviously
grown up with it but how does someone
who came from like
investment banking you know get into
obviously he has so much money
which is which is one of the things
you'll probably need is money which is
the biggest thing i've found out i
didn't notice like just
even just one day of drifting for us
where like some of us barely learned
anything i i feel um still costs a lot
of money yeah
yeah so how do you get into it like how
do you take that that original leap and
how do you know you want to do it
i mean the the pattern most people take
uh i mean when i started at least is you
start with your daily driver
you have some sort of car which can
drift and you just
try and make sure it doesn't break too
much okay you know like
you get this i mean well let's be frank
most people start off on the street
right some quiet street somewhere i mean
that's what most you know like a parking
lot or something like a parking lot or
an
in in the case of australia like an
industrial area or like some
mountain roads somewhere like a windy
road somewhere where you just go you'll
sit there for a few minutes and
okay there's no one coming up behind me
there's no traffic okay let's go and you
do a little lap or something or
you know you have you go with friends
and spotters and things like that so
there's that
um the best way is to go to a circuit
uh the way what got me the when i
started to understand the feeling was i
had an rx7 back when i was like 18 i'd
go to i'd go to the track and drive
around and
you know it was all very like oh yes you
know grip driving and
getting good times and breaking points
and clipping points and all sort of
stuff i'm like
this is kind of this is kind of boring
it's just kind of like doing the same
thing again and again yeah but then i'd
come in a bit too hot
and break too late in the back of the
car and sort of step out like
oh yes dude that was sick i'll do that
again
try and like come out of the corner put
a you know you if you come out of a
corner you press the accelerator really
hard
i mean look it's like video games do the
same thing mario kart whatever it's like
you do something and the back of the car
slides out
yeah and you yeah i do that but then you
have the flag masters like
don't drift that don't don't they get
all annoyed at you so
we would uh we started a little club in
in australia in sydney
where i'm from and you know certainly
and we have track days
and we just go out there and you just do
it like you just try like we watch
these japanese videos and all these
weird videos where they're talking i
can't understand what they're saying but
it's like
yeah okay i will try that i can't
understand what they're saying but they
pull some sick drifts
basically yeah the best thing these days
is it's
so accessible now like these days you
can right there's
millions of videos and everything you
can just get into it's super easy you're
one of them right i
feel like yeah i feel like no amount of
videos could prepare me
like i actually tried to before the day
of the drift circuit i actually tried to
watch like a basic like how to drift
video
[ __ ] didn't help any by the way
because there's there's no
there's no like you you can read up
about it and learn about it all you want
but there's a different feeling where
you have to like
when you're just in this car seat in the
moment and you just have to like
you kind of have to feel your way
through yeah it's it's a it's a massive
seat of the pants thing
uh where you're you're trying to unlearn
what you already know like if you're not
if you're already a regular driver
it's you're doing everything is the
exact opposite of what you should be
doing you're not supposed to rev the
engine you're not supposed to dump the
clutch you're not supposed to spin the
wheels you're not supposed to slide
around you're not supposed to do any of
that stuff yeah
so it's the you know the yoda you must
unlearn what you have learned
and and that can be a bit of a hurdle uh
for some people
and for other people who maybe have a
bit more of a feel for it then it's a
bit
you get over that hump a bit faster but
honestly look anybody can do it
it's not it's not an unusual skill right
to be able to drift i mean yeah i i
managed to somewhat pull it off at the
end of the day and yet you know i went
into it not knowing how to drive a
manual at all
right so yeah it's not an unusual skill
but
uh i mean the the gap is obviously as
you said like the commitment to keep
doing it is a huge yeah
yeah because you have to buy i mean you
have to i actually have to buy a car
dedicated to drift you can't just
do people use their like daily commute
yeah they do some well
can they drift oh okay
you don't need you don't need a crazy
car to be able to drift you need some
like minor modifications but
generally any rear wheel drive car can
drift
reasonably easy yeah uh and
the the downside is though like if you
have to go to work on a monday morning
and you've just you broke something on
you know i i was going to say that i've
done that too like you've you know i've
broken a gear box at the track and i
have to go to work on the monday and
it's like well i've only got like first
second and fifth gear it's like okay
it's like
just go around me i can't yeah
there's that but you know these days um
you know people will have dedicated
track cars and again
that adds a whole extra level of money
to it because i noticed when we were at
a business there was so many like
foreigner friendly stuff and it was like
yeah
come come buy a car just come drift here
yeah every so the thing about ebisu is
abc is very special abc is probably one
of the
if every suit didn't exist that would be
one less reason for me to originally
move here
right so it's been around for a long
time a long time episode was the track
that we were drifting out
yes yeah abc circuit up in fukushima uh
it
what makes it special is it's drift
friendly
it has not one track but many tracks
with different
sizes about seven yeah i mean there's
some like open skid pans and stuff like
that
they're all different kinds of tracks a
lot of very famous drift videos
uh like you watch it famous drift video
oh that's where it was right
especially the you didn't you guys
didn't go to it there's a track called
minami
the south circuit which is infamous for
being extremely difficult and extremely
rewarding to drive
it's extremely dangerous it's eaten i've
seen it break
legs and ribs from people crashing there
people i saw a guy right off his car an
american guy
on his second lap he bought the car
there no
second lap he went over the entry just
went straight into the wall banana the
front end
done have you ever had any bad injuries
or have you ever
had any bad crashes or anything like
that not knock knock on wood no
you shouldn't ask someone you shouldn't
ask the person to drive cars that sort
of question
oh my god what an [ __ ] yeah a lot of
i mean a lot of
small crashes but i mean that sort of
comes with it but yeah i've seen
personally i've seen um there actually
there has been some big very severe
injuries at msu circuit from
i mean i can i can only write yeah yeah
right yeah yeah it's a motorsport you
yeah
it can be quite sketchy it used to be it
used to be a lot better because
the speeds were lower and people weren't
quite as extreme now but now everyone
wants everyone's just going flat out the
whole time
yeah yeah that's terrifying cars rolling
over and
okay here's the question i want to ask
though as someone who like is into the
drift scene obviously
initial d legit or no okay
uh because i've always wanted to know
like
you know because initial d is like kind
of put on this pedestal of like yes this
is the
drift anime yeah and even though there's
other ones like one gun midnight and
like all these other great ones
it's always like initial days like the
cream of the crop right yeah so i want
to know like as someone who's into that
scene
and who's probably watched a lot of
initial days i've seen all of it yeah
yeah
legit or not legit okay it's it's
that is like sort of saying like okay
you've if it's like saying saying
someone who is like
into computers saying is hackers like is
that
whatever or like um you know someone
who's into surfing like oh it's point
break like is that what it's actually
like right
it's it's like yes it's based a lot on
reality
obviously there's a lot of dramatization
yeah yeah but honestly
initial d is pretty good
as far as stuff is concerned now
so going all the way back to the start
uh the got the mangaka
uh shigenosuichi who wrote that
he his specialty is sort of like you
know teenage
romantic drama
and motorsports sort of thing
combination yeah i don't know i guess
it's like sort of a 1990s japan
yeah yeah um he's done other ones like
um buddy buddy densetsu which is based
around motorcycle racing
that was also an anime as well um there
was another one i
think it's like some something something
blue sky i forgot the name of it which
was like the precursor to initial d
where like the main character drove an
a86
you know and um that's that's the main
car in initial duties yeah and it was
set at like some sort of
rich kids summer like tennis camp or
something like that i don't know
right drifting around the tenders well
there was some sort of thing with like i
don't know anyway so
then then came out initial day so yes
that's
it's mostly true because back then in
the late 80s early 90s
uh if you went up to the mountains in
you know
gunma saitama uh anywhere around tokyo
you'd find
dudes in like these little cheap ripple
drive corollas or sylvias or things like
that yeah
just just having just you know having
fun sliding around
uh having you know enjoying uh you know
a saturday night yeah
and at the same time too yes there were
races
done up there i've spoken to this is one
of those things where the reality
is almost better than the fiction right
oh okay i've spoken to people i've
actually met the real
the like the takumi fujiwara like the
real guy the guy who inspired
yeah yeah yeah there's a guy um he he
worked at a
uh at a tofu shop and he would deliver
the tofu up to the
the top of the mountain or some stuff
it's all based on reality yeah
um so cool like there's one guy i've i
know i've done a i did a job with him
once where he's uh a gymkhana champion
of japan
jim carter is where you uh it's like
like what you did with the cones
yeah yeah you've got to drive around as
fast as possible like an obstacle course
yeah you've got to remember it too it's
like you're going to go four then
backwards here and around this three
times
it's very complicated it was a bit more
complicated than what we did
and so he's like one of the japanese
champions and i was talking
about yeah we used to go out to this
certain mountain i had a crx out there
and i was the fastest guy on the
mountain then one day
these guys showed up with a bunch of
civics and they were faster than me and
i was like oh i need to beat these guys
we had races and it's like
this sounds exactly like an initial deal
a little gang war
yeah yeah it's the same thing and like
all the stuff you've seen initially like
for example there's a scene in that
where um a bunch of gangsters come up
the mountain
to like one of the one of the other
street racers calls like
a bunch of gang members to come up to
fight of course one of the types of
brothers and then then they're all
they'll see the
takashi and they're like oh senpai like
that's real like guys would see this
thing about because it's street racing
it's not legal
right yeah so guys who are out to look
for fights would actually go up there
and like try to start fights with street
races
all these little points you see in the
in that are like based on some sort of
reality
okay yeah that's that's pretty that's
right it's pretty good like
they talk about the like the different
kinds of cars that um you know their
strengths and weaknesses
and like some cars on certain uh toga
and stuff like that like like the what
there's a the one with the uh the spiral
gtr which loses its brakes going down a
hill
right and the other two cars have to go
in front like stop it with
like that's not i i know someone who had
to do that in real life
oh my god i was watching your videos and
i thought there was just like uh
an a-a-a-e a e-80 86 like a meetup
like in the place where it was [ __ ]
tons of them yeah yeah
that was so cool yeah so i i guess
fortunately or unfortunately
i guess it's one of the things that made
me confident to reach out to you guys
was
some of my most popular videos on my
youtube channel are based around initial
d
yeah of course yeah and anime culture as
well yeah well
uh yeah it's uh it it's i mean if you
think about it it's just a very
expensive cosplay
it's like cosplay yeah it's like a
weapon but really
yeah like all the all the if you at that
show there was the
there was the main characters you know
corolla there was the uh the the takashi
brothers rx7s
even the uh the new manga that's out now
uh uh what's it called ghost
uh mf ghost yeah maybe like the new
eight six with the number on the door
like there's
the people do cosplays of these like car
cosplays it's cosplay with attitude
that's what it is and i noticed that
even like the the japanese people like
knew you were like fans of you
oh yeah i mean because you're just like
because you go to these events so often
you kind of like i go to
these events also like a lot of my
videos that i know are going to be
popular with japanese people i have
subtitles on them as well
there's not there's not a lot of uh car
content being
like car youtubers in japan i mean there
are but um
i think people often say like i've
because i'm looking at it from a
different
perspective yeah yeah like i'm like oh
look it's the initial d
car it's like because if a japanese
person does it's kind of cringy i guess
to them
yeah it's like yeah yeah yeah it's a
little weird how they all like that with
kind of anime yeah like stuff that is a
reference to an anime
and it's like oh yeah yeah this is
initial d thing i get anyway whatever
dude it's like be proud of it yeah it's
cool
i mean i i guess for me drifting has
always been so ingrained in
japanese well like japanese culture and
japanese car culture because if it
wasn't for stuff like initial d
or like tokyo drift i would have no idea
about drifting yeah you're like
meme's aside about tokyo drift like it
is legit the only reason
i knew that japan was famous like as a
kid so
talking to you dying inside talking to
you about like the international drift
scene i'm gonna be honest like i had no
idea there was an international drift
scene i thought
it was like all japan and everyone was
following that like
it used to be like that it's not right i
mean nowadays
okay so i've sort of come to peace with
initial d and um and fast and furious
and that sort of stuff like it's like
you know i mean look it's like anything
where like you're into something there's
a movie about it people go oh yeah i saw
that movie like
it's not like that but the fact that it
makes it it's it's an easy it's a wedge
to open a conversation people sort of
understand
yeah i'm fine with it it's the same
thing with with um with tokyo drift like
the majority of that i mean you can
probably look at the japan side of and
go
no that's not actually what it's like
here yeah certain but it is in certain
ways but you know they
people don't drift in car parks like
yeah
i must say that's just very
irresponsible yeah yeah yeah
no it i mean you you see the if you're
gonna see drifting in tokyo it's to be
like down on the the
docks in like the big open areas where
it's right right like
midnight for example yeah like that's
something i think they had a scene in
tokyo drift at the docks i'm pretty sure
they did
they did they actually did yeah i did my
research
over the car park scene though because
like looking because you go into any car
park in like tokyo or whatever
like you can barely drive it's like yeah
like the [ __ ]
hatsu boxes can barely get through and
then you're like what the [ __ ]
that's probably the most inaccurate
thing about that but the rest of it like
you know the general theme of what they
talk about is do you like the movie
that's a loaded question honestly i
think i would genuinely like it the
movie for its campiness if the main
actor wasn't so [ __ ] awful
yeah [ __ ] can't stand his accent
every time every time he speaks japanese
i do
cringe oh yeah right it's so bad
there's a cuts there's a scene that's
been cut out of the movie where they uh
they steal a bunch of tires from a
petrol station all right and it's got um
what's the guys uh little little
little dog snoop what's the character's
name the the actual actor
um eight dog no no no the the the guy in
the movie um he's like sidekick
he's sidekick character i know he's like
a wrestler yeah he's a rapper he's
already
uh anyway it'll be on screen there's a
scene where like he distracts the
the staff by like speak by you know he
opens a drink and like because it
doesn't have any fears he's like
nani correa like
[Laughter]
it's just so bad oh wow it's so bad but
look
it's fine like i said i've come to peace
with it yeah like i said it's horrible
campiness
but it is a good general overview and
there are there are some scenes where
they kind of get into the
the you know the side of where it's kind
of like uh being you know escaping from
reality and free because
it honestly it is like that like you
know you go up to the mountains at two
in the morning
and all you can hear is like the sound
of the crickets and
uh that and maybe a river nearby and
that's it and then all of a sudden you
hear this like screaming coming from the
distance and it's
you know a bunch of cars and the
headlights shining through the trees
yeah
it is very cool yeah right i've seen
i've seen footage of like the late night
drifting stuff and it's like yeah
there's a part of me that's like oh man
that'd be so cool to be in but then at
the same time i'm like
so now i i i i i i like my life yeah you
know what i mean
exactly basically what i'm getting out
of this is like initial d
isn't realistic enough compared to tokyo
drift look man i think the the
again the reality is
the stories that i've heard see a lot of
those guys don't want to talk about it
too because they don't they just want to
keep it
yeah yeah yeah but when you can get them
talking
like if they've been drinking and stuff
like that like you're just sitting there
going
holy [ __ ] how are you still alive
yeah wow yeah it's really good it's so
cool it's like a lot of stuff like in
japan too where you
you get here and you meet these people i
mean same thing with with you know this
industry too it's like you meet them and
you hear what they did and stuff they've
done it's like
i i almost feel like because of how the
culture is and how like
strict everything is i've met like the
craziest [ __ ] people here that might
just do not give a [ __ ] and they're like
all right this is what i used to do
and i feel like i've never met anyone
like this in the uk because everyone's
kind of like i don't really care about
the rules but yeah
when you get a society that's so strict
that normally you get characters yeah
and there you hear some of the craziest
stories that
you know you you don't normally hear
about and you know you
really have to drag it out of them yeah
you know what i mean they'll just
mention like this offhand or off the
cuff thing you're like
say something like what what please
elaborate
yeah i mean so you were mentioning that
you were you know
initial d very well and all that anime
but i'm curious do you know actually
like any other anime or any other are
you into any anime
you are in an anime podcast yeah okay so
um one of the anime podcasts
one of the things that maybe a bit more
confident to reach out to you guys was
that i used to be
massively like into anime a lot hell
yeah
yeah like how long ago were we talking
okay so
it's 20 20 now i was in probably
it's like middle school high school so
like we're talking like 1994
i'd say was 92 93 94
school i was two years old
this is the era of vhs rental tapes and
right right of course just going forward
like you know uh
people you know irc list serves and
stuff like downloading random
getting throttled you know downloading
too much stuff
swapping cds and you know things like
that so how did you get anime back then
how did you get
how does one get into anime back then
what was what was like the entry point
oh wow well i mean probably i mean most
people say like oh yeah i saw
uh what what was the actual name from
macros uh robo like roberto
okay so every time i would see and this
sort of
i watched the uh the podcast with um uh
with chris yeah when he talked about
this sort of thing where just every time
you see something from japan there was
just something about it that just kind
of resonated
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah you just see
like yeah i i
this is my aesthetic i like this yeah so
every time i saw and sometimes you know
you don't realize what it is and you're
like oh
oh that was actually a japanese anime
right or like even stuff like inspect
the gadget which was
you know it was a french all those
french japanese productions back then
like i just
yeah just something about because it was
animated in japan yeah yeah and
slowly slowly it just starts to be like
you see this tape at the civic
video which is my local rental shop like
what is this crazy looking thing this
rated r18
oh you take it to the candy like because
i don't care it's like oh it's it's just
some animation here whatever like that
yeah
it's like you know um uh wicked city and
oh oh oh wicked city dude so you got
into anime during like the [ __ ]
80s 90s ova bloomberg the manga vhs era
oh
my god it was yeah it was amazing
everything every i just go there and
rent that stuff and it just it just
you know went from there to uh that was
kind of like a golden age in and of
itself
yeah because it was like everything you
could like anime was so brutal back then
everything was devilman crybaby yeah
pretty much you know what i mean like
wicked city ninja scroll
yeah vampire hunter violence jack yeah
[ __ ] like that was just like
so [ __ ] up it was so good cyber city
808
yeah so i'm actually wearing this is the
my akira shirt that's such a secret
shirt right so this is this is about 20
something years old
i just don't know wow today although
again akira all that sort of stuff it's
just like blows your mind like oh this
is so cool and it was just always
you know enjoyable um any sort of media
you can just get your hands on uh back
then
like the uk video game magazines were
very good with that sort of thing like
they'd
they you know about that no so there was
a from what i could tell there was a
huge
like imports like grey import scene back
in the day for video games so people
would
they'd be playing like japanese stuff
all the time these certain video game
magazines they'd feature a lot of
japanese content i do remember like
roughly having some memory
of seeing a lot of japanese stuff
growing up which is why i think
eventually i did get into it because i
always thought like every like you said
every time you see it you're like man
that's really [ __ ]
cool yeah it always just happened to be
japanese stuff that was always the thing
that
like stuck out to me yeah so was it like
a like a nintendo power but like not a
legend you had a lot of those in the uk
yeah there are a lot of them yeah like
it was called hyper it was called hyper
that sounds familiar yeah it was i'm
pretty sure it's a magazine called hyper
and i've managed to find a big like
download dump of it a while like every
issue scanned i was like
gaming publications in the uk and stuff
like that were huge for a very long time
cv and g or whatever it was i can't
remember but i remember that there was
just like everyone had demo discs from
the magazines
i remember those days the ps1 demo discs
that you get with them
we did have that where we did yeah and
just stuff would be you know you'd
it'd be like some sort of video game
where you'd see it and it's like you'd
find out later like oh that was actually
like a japanese game yeah yeah yeah that
particular sort of thing right yeah so i
mean look
it and it just it snowballed from there
i didn't have any friends who were into
it in
in my school not nobody
not even like maybe like one kid from
hong kong or like kind of like dragon
ball like that
why is it always dragon ball yeah i
don't know so yeah you have like some of
the little cards whatever
yeah and you know it got to the point
where it's things like
going to specialty shops and like
ordering like say i remember i bought
the uh
when evangelion came out like the movie
yeah i ordered the vhs tape because it
first came out of vhs yeah no subtitles
i wanted the best the highest quality
and i downloaded the script
my original yeah my my original
experience of the ava movie was
sitting there going you were fan subbing
yourself
you were like live fan sobbing
evangelion that's crazy
oh my god dude i swear i like i i feel
that but like this is embarrassing
when i watch [ __ ] like shakespeare
and like the globe theater i couldn't
[ __ ] understand
because they they they talk in like an
older version i don't know what type of
english it's called
speaking english i was like [ __ ]
online like following the story i'm like
oh oh this is that part i couldn't
understand a [ __ ] thing but obviously
yours is a lot more understandable same
thing but you you get it it's like but
unfortunately there's that one scene
where can i spoil it or not
is it old enough spoiler alert also it's
[ __ ] ava why haven't you watched ava
yeah
where where oscar gets stabbed through
the head and they're ripped apart yeah i
i
accidentally read that too early
[Laughter]
and she's like one of my favorites one
of my favorite characters is like you
know
uh eva gets violently ripped apart i'm
like
and then they all died
i remember feeling it was like two in
the morning i remember feeling sick i
was like oh my god oh
my god oh yeah it was it was a it was an
it was a thing man like yeah so it just
that was a brutal scene too yeah yeah
yeah so it just brought it went from
there
then
i i feel old when i talk about talk
about hard-coded fan subs you know what
i mean
yeah right and now we're talking about
[ __ ] [ __ ] hardcoded fan subs how
about on paper
printed paper fans like
25 sheets of paper it was it was about
that thing
did they have like translated notes and
everything to like no that was like
it was planned it was pretty good like
it was it was designed
for people to read like to read and
watch right
said it pretty well yeah it was it was
crazy downloaded off like
um you know something like some weird
website
so you're like more of an og anime fan
than any of us do we would we'd do
things like where we'd swap
vhs tapes like you'd what you do is
watch it yeah i've heard about i feel
like
you have like your list of all your
content you have that like somewhere
and then people you're friends with like
they'd say hey can do
i want that what do you want from mine
and you'd make a copy of the tape and
send it to each other
that sounds so fun i i want to ask like
because we like growing up we had the
problem of like our anime was for
example on youtube and sometimes there
would be like
an episode or a part of an episode that
wasn't uploaded
what was it like for you where you had
to actually get physical
vhs saves were you just did you have to
like watch anime episodes out of order
or like
if some episodes were available you just
get them anyway i think it was
i mean because the thing about that is
it's much easier to delete things
than you know so that's why like
something would be a copyright or
whatever i don't know whatever
channel would go down yeah but back then
like everybody had like physical media
so it all like
exists like it's not going to disappear
as long as you didn't lose the physical
tape
yeah as long as you had it it's like
it's there and you know that someone
else has
like they can just make a copy and send
it to you so physically
yeah and people would be very goes back
then people like hardcore
into it so they'd have a complete
collection that wasn't really an issue
no right
if you wanted to see something it was
was it expensive oh man i don't even
know how much i've spent
yeah right because i yeah people out
here complaining about a six sellers
monthly subscription yeah yeah
if i could pay that six bucks a month
back then for
almost unlimited you know yeah wow
that's uh
how much stuff how much consumers so how
much did you have to pay for like
a single vhs table and or like a like if
you wanted to watch an anime a series
or what would that cost okay so the the
best thing was when
uh the australian distributors like
madman and stuff started to make
because you the japanese discs would
have like
two or three episodes yeah yeah it'd be
like sixty dollars
yeah it's like it's it's like that to
this day as well yeah yeah right
i just don't get it whereas overseas
that's the best thing like america and
other countries where
they make you know it's like the whole
season of one of one's thing it's like
that that's how it should be
right it's still good quality and
subtitles and everything so yeah i mean
but i didn't really
i didn't really spend money on anything
else i was just i think
you went from one expensive hobby to
another man
so that makes me curious then how did
you because obviously i've seen in your
videos as well you can
speak japanese like i'm much better than
being gone
like 100 um how did you
were you learning japanese before you
moved to japan and also when did you
move to japan like what made you do that
uh so i so i used to work at a car
magazine in australia
okay so but originally so what i did was
went to university didn't like that
studied through it's just that quick
you're like yeah two lessons in i'm done
you'll be like that we'll be like a
smoke break
yeah it just never came back i was just
like it's like whatever it's just
something i don't know what i want to do
and so i but i uh in the meantime while
i was doing that i was studying
animation
all right like actual like physical with
pieces of paper and i was super hardcore
into this sort of stuff yeah so you know
i had my own thing and i was doing like
little test things or whatever uh so
then i started to learn 3d animation and
this is back when
if you heard of the program maya oh yeah
maya this is like my i was learning like
maya 1.5 or something
yeah original it was running on irix
boxes which is a
silicon graphics irix which is like a
unix proprietary unix
and one box would be like twelve
thousand dollars
jesus yeah to learn on so i was i
learned this i learned this 3d software
because i wanted
to do animation like that's what i liked
yeah and did that
got jobs doing that which paid really
well back then because no one knew how
to do it
yeah it was very you had to be you had
to know you had to churn out content
real quick
and so i was i was young i was like 23
or 4 or something and
i just i go there in the morning and
work hours and hours and
you know nothing else to do so i'd
always get the work done got paid really
good
but let's go and watch anime
so then i got kind of burned out on that
right doing
it wasn't what i'd imagined it was a lot
how long were you doing that for
uh probably about five six years oh wow
it was i mean it was good um but it's
very high you know
the crunches and things like that yeah
he like they just shovel content
here do all this stuff and you're like
this sucks and just sit there all day
but at the same time i've got my
headphones on listening to japanese
lessons
listening to you know because for some
reason like i think if you're doing
creative work and language it doesn't
mix in your
right yeah i could sort of listen
konichiwa oh
oh mr you know
like just again and again and again so
it just stuck right right while i'm
doing that so
then got burned out of that came to
japan i wanted to do anime stuff and car
stuff
right how how did you come here like
what was the process like or did you get
like a
no i i just a tourist oh just tours does
as a tourist uh i wanted to see car
stuff i wanted to see anime stuff so i
went to
you know akihabara i had the it was all
in a notebook all written out and
no no google maps none of this i didn't
know what i was looking for so
what year is this this is like 2005. oh
oh my goodness yeah yeah it was like not
i was blind
yeah yeah every like i had i had two
friends who'd been to japan
one who done car stuff one who'd done
he'd sort of gone to akihabara yeah so
he's like drawing me
hand-drawn maps of like okay so this is
the last building and if you turn this
way there's the bridge and you walk that
way because that's where all the stuff
is like
okay um because i didn't have any
friends who wanted to do car stuff anime
stuff
so you've done the same thing i'm sure
you
you burn yourself out you get up in the
morning you go do stuff
all day you don't eat you don't drink
you just do more all this sort of stuff
you go in the hotel fall asleep wake up
just do it again
so i go out again and went up to abc
circuit by myself
and you went all the way to fukushima by
yourself
no i took the train okay i was blind
a friend of mine who was the who worked
at a magazine actually a friend of a
friend
he worked at a magazine and i just said
he sort of knew who i was so i messaged
him like
well i i emailed him and said hey can
you tell me how to get the bbc circuit
he said just go to nihon matsu station
and just get in the taxi and just say
absolute circuit
are you going there i'm like yeah oh can
you write an article
about the the event right for the
magazine
yeah so i've got my mom's little
panasonic
like digital camera oh 32 megabyte
memory cards
not gigabyte megabytes so i go up there
i
i see the event just blows my mind yeah
yeah cool stuff it's a big competition
uh which i i now do the commentary for
which is kind of cool yeah
full circle yeah go back i write this
article and then i was like oh it was
really good
and then a few weeks you know about a
month later do you want a job
yes i'm sick of doing 3d i hate it so i
started working the magazine
and every chance i'd i could i come to
japan
and this is how we did it this is how
these people have to remember this sort
of stuff
you somehow make money when you come
here
right if you can like people do that by
making youtube videos and stuff like
that
yeah yeah yeah yeah so what i did was i
would come here go do car stuff
i'd take photos of it write articles go
back and i i get paid for going on
holiday
right it's a double win yeah right it's
like this is this is perfect
i have games the system right
okay i've got this figured out and it
got to the point where
literally everyone i knew was like lexi
just shut the [ __ ] up and go live there
that's all you talk about oh like my car
friends everyone's like
alexis japanese japan well in japan well
in japan they do this in japan do that
so just go i said okay fine
i will so working holiday visa right
right 18 months okay i'm gonna
i'm gonna quit everything sell
everything i'm gonna live there for a
year and a half if it works out if it
i've had a good holiday i can i can just
shut up about and get it out of my
system yeah
we'll see what happens yeah so came here
and
just did the same thing just you know
went around shooting articles
writing things selling them to magazines
selling them to all around the world in
english
and it just sort of built up from there
so like you know taking photos
oh look at these cool random photos i've
taken of this cool stuff i'll make a
wordpress
wordpress blog which is what everybody
did back then yeah this is like 2008.
yeah yeah yeah okay wordpress blog then
at the same time so that became a
popular thing
then you know i oh this is really cool
i've got this little
sony vloggy you know camera it only
shows
i think i have the exact same camera
yeah it's like oh
let's just shoot this car doing
something cool because it looks you know
it's moving it's making noise
that's what makes them cool is it the
old like sony handycams
it was original it's a tiny little one
oh okay so
so shoot all that and then that goes on
youtube well that becomes more popular
uh you know magazines aren't popular
they don't make any money anymore they
don't want to pay
eight hundred thousand dollars for a big
article these days yeah
okay youtube pays money let's do youtube
and it's just sort of snowballed from
there so then how did you transition
from
doing all the online stuff into then
actually like
living here permanently because i assume
you had to figure out a way right
yeah i mean this is one of the biggest
questions you know everyone wants to
like how do you live in japan
because you get it all the time as well
yeah yeah i mean
i mean let's uh it's it's a difficult
thing because
there's so many people i'm sure you've
had the same experience like people who
are living here it's like
how are you living here like you don't
you think like do you you have to do
something
what visa do you have how how how have
you
coined how how do you game the system in
your own way right it's a it's sort of
like uh
uh you're not supposed to ask that
question like
how what vision how are you here like
because well look some people just
um you know they're lucky like oh my
my father is japanese i've got a visa
yeah yeah or like um i'm not lucky you
know what i mean like almost like it's a
bad thing
yeah well like you know some for some
reason they're here
uh so the way i did it was um
so originally working holiday visa and
then when that started to run out
was i thought okay i need to do
something and i had a friend
who lived up in um uh
sendai who was a french guy and he was
actually running a mag as a french
magazine he was running the magazine as
the editor from japan
oh okay so he was just getting all this
content from japan just
editing it yeah and it was so he was on
a journalist visa
oh okay so i thought he said you should
do the journalist visa it's very easy
so sorry jc that's bad
um so i i thought okay maybe i can do
this so i applied for everything
now remember when the earthquake oh you
went here when the earthquake happened
the earthquake
yeah the earthquake happened right and
and i'd already sort of renewed once and
it worked and i thought okay i don't
know if i can do this again
uh it was kind of easy the first time
because i
i managed to get like a contract from a
magazine right
and i don't know if it would work these
days or not but
you know i had proof that i'd been doing
that job for a long time and the best
thing about being a journalist is you
don't need any sort of
uh qualification yeah you don't all you
need is like i've done this for a long
time
yeah i'm gonna keep doing it these guys
gonna pay me to do it okay so i sort of
convinced them a magazine to give me a
contract like look
you want this content give me a contract
yeah right
okay so i got that i showed them uh then
again that whole earthquake thing
happened um
and this was like literate at the same
time i was meant to renew i thought oh
no what if they
cancel me or right so i mean look
everyone i don't know about you guys
it's in like a panic state
it's all it's all what was that like
okay
when i uh it was it was wasn't bad for
me because all i did was just sort of
sit at home for like a month and just do
nothing i just thought
i'm just going to stay the hell out of
it yeah yeah until i need to do
something actually my
um i did go and help a friend who it was
at ebisu uh who had a lot of trouble
with
stuff falling down the hill like it
collapsed anyway yeah right right right
so
i thought okay i i i don't want to leave
if i leave now
probably not going to come back yeah
right because a lot of the whole fl you
haven't fly gin you heard that
term like no yeah so foreigners who left
japan when the earthquake happened was
like i'm out
was that a real thing yeah a lot of
foreigners like yeah well okay
it was it was kind of a dorothy thing
it's like yeah you left it's like i
honestly don't blame people who did that
because it was that bad understandable
have a nice day footage of it but it's
so hard to like actually get a sense of
it because even the small earthquakes
here kind of like throw me off sometimes
yeah
i can only imagine what an earthquake of
that magnitude i don't know
if i don't know i don't think people can
quote me on this but wasn't it like one
of the most like
financially it was one of the most like
devastating earthquakes
slash tsunamis of like all time or
something well probably the deadliest
yeah i think it like caused the most
damage like financially and yeah it
really caused a lot of problems
really [ __ ] up this japanese economy
depending on how severe
i hear it was is depending on who i
asked and where they were at the time
yeah because some people said like i've
been told this like it wasn't that bad
things just started
falling yeah it was bad other people
yeah but like so i'm saying right
depends on who you ask and whether you
were at the time right because obviously
if someone experienced it and it wasn't
bad for them they probably think like
i mean it was on like every year
like it was you know it was [ __ ]
worldwide
no i i know i'm not saying it's not what
i'm asking is like how was it for like
you because everyone i seem to ask so
far has such a different explanation for
me
personally i mean when it actually
happened i was uh so i was about i was
just doing some washing at the time it
was like a because it's like in the
afternoon
i thought uh i'm going to take it down
to the laundromat and get the dryer
going
and some things i was going to hang up
as well and
the windows started rattling i'm like oh
it's windy good i can get my mic
if i can watch this hang my sheets out
get them to dry
and then all of a sudden everything
started i was on the second floor of a
of a house that i used to live in yeah
it started to move i'm like oh
earthquake okay um
what do i do okay staying in the so i
stood in the door in the door frame
right
he's supposed to do it yes i think
that's what you're supposed to do and it
started to
it's just doing this and i'm like okay
this is bad wait i'm supposed to be a
media guy where's my camera
so i grabbed my bloggie again yeah and i
caught the last like 20 seconds
on video and like i aimed out the window
all the lines are
the power lines are doing this and it's
rattling and it's just crazy
and i remember it like that too and then
it's just kind of stopped and
there was a guy doing a delivery like a
i couldn't echo guy over the road he
just kept doing this stamp and he go and
yeah like nothing happened yeah it's
gonna happen and i'm looking at there's
no
smoke rising it's okay it should be okay
and so i
put my stuff in my laundry anything went
down to the laundromat and i'm in there
just sitting there waiting for it to dry
i was like okay i'll go shopping maybe
in a minute
and these kids walk past the window
outside wearing those
uh those those hats you know the foam
yeah
yeah it's like it's it's like this like
kind of uh it's like a triangle it's
like a bandana looking thing that they
wear and it's supposed to be fireproof
yeah yeah kids like elementary school
kids wear it to like kind of protect
themselves it's like a red riding hood
hood but it's like a thick foam with
like made of reflectives like an old
fireman's hat sort of thing my god yeah
in the uk
they're like [ __ ] get on with it i
mean there's nothing that
happens in the uk that's big enough to
be worried about right they'll walk past
the window i'm like what the hell are
these oh oh they're wearing those things
okay
and then in the laundry room there's tv
sometimes there's a tv yeah right
and i look up and there's that the big
black wall of death just eating town
wow oh [ __ ] i better go get some i
better go and buy some food or something
so i i just i went to the supermarket
and just bought a bunch of food and i
thought
i can and a slab of beer i thought
yes so it was okay for me like the worst
thing for doing car content was there
was no fuel
yeah they just cut all the fuel got cut
off so i was like okay and what i
actually did that month was i had enough
of an internet presence then to say
that i had a regular column in a
japanese magazine actually and i said
hey everyone send me a picture of your
foreign drift car and i got people to do
make my content for me yeah
but you're a pro youtuber yeah yeah yeah
damn but up in uh
in in tohoku like up where especially
is absolutely yeah i had to go up there
to help a friend just
so you weren't in sendai when it
actually happened no no no i wasn't up
there yeah because
because my grandma lives in sendai sorry
she like uh yeah because what i've heard
is that from people who were in sendai
near the epicenter was
awful but then i've heard a lot of
people in tokyo who are like yeah things
were shaking yeah well i mean
for my grandma i was kind of like half
off because like she
lives on like a quite a big like
apartment place right yeah i think she
was on like the 13th or 14th floor or
something
and like obviously the higher up on the
building you are right the
more it's going to [ __ ] but like
you know it didn't break anything like
she didn't get injured or whatever but
then she did tell me that like it was
really scary that
after the rattling kind of stopped and
she picked herself back up and looked
out the window
she could actually see the tsunami
coming over the horizon oh my
god and and then she was like oh [ __ ]
and she turned the tv on and then you
know the that really famous like footage
right
yeah wall was just uh wait what is the
black wall it's
i i just made like that's crazy i just
made that up yeah it's
just the tsunami was just like a big
churning
dark mess it wasn't like this like one
big wave that most people think it is it
was kind of just this
rush of water they're just coming in
because of like
because it was just taking all the
debris with it
right so it's just like uh it just turns
to a black wolf like destruction
because it wasn't like it was hardly
water anymore because it was just like
all the gunk that you would have
taken out all the houses that were along
the coast were just getting crushed
as this thing came over and it was yeah
it was horrible meanwhile international
people like were like
but my anime
trains were cancelled for a while and
they had rolling blackouts
yeah luckily because i was the grid that
i was on at my house was um the same
grid as a big hospital
and a japanese military base so we never
got a cut right here's the thing so
what i'm saying before was i had to
renew my visa
and at that point you had to get a
re-entry visa to come back into the
country
right which meant you have to go to the
visa center get like a 20
stamp in your thing your passport so if
you leave the country you can come back
and everyone's leaving because it's like
well
there's radiation landing yeah i mean
understandably yeah yeah yeah so and i
was just
i thought okay fine but i was like
trying to renew my thing at the same
time so i went to the visa center
at like three in the afternoon which is
a bad idea i drove there
out in saitama right and the queue was
about 300 meters long
of people i thought what is this anime
expo i had to i thought okay
here's what i have to do okay i have to
come back tomorrow morning
before the first train yeah so my car
because my car ran on premium
fuel this is a drift car right uh no no
fuel
i don't know i like it to mention yeah
just reminding you i'm interested
it was a drift car okay so i i i begged
my friend like please lend me your
little cake
your little small compact car so i can
drive in there before the first train so
i can get in line get there there's
already about
maybe 50 meters of people lined up oh my
god i didn't get in the front door until
i lined up at
like maybe 4 30 in the morning didn't
get there in the front door until
two in the afternoon and then as soon as
i got in the front door
everyone's going to the left i go to the
right to renew
right and i walk up there's not at the
counter because they're all busy over
here i'm like right
um and some someone walks past like um
what do you want
oh i want to renew they're like oh okay
they just take it they sort of just
flicked through like
you got you got your tax thing in there
it's like oh i i i forgot that it's like
i don't worry about it
they just couldn't believe
and then and then just as i went back i
was like oh that's over thank god for
that i can go home
went to the car park to get my coin
parking little gates
right so get in the car go to drive out
and go to the gate put my money in the
machine all i had was a hundred
like a ten thousand yen like a hundred
yeah you can put them in the machines
here put it in the machine
the gates open it's like where's my
change
four o'clock scheduled blackout oh
no so the machine ate my hundred dollar
bill i'm like oh no
yeah like i look around like all the all
the lights are blanked out
coming out of the bank because it just
got blacked out i'm like oh no so anyway
i i called up and
this being japan there was a very lovely
girl and she's like you know
answering the phone yeah i'm sorry the
machine ate my hundred dollars she's
like oh don't worry we'll
oh okay we'll we'll make sure we'll make
sure it's okay we'll send you the money
we'll get you information of your bank
sure enough like a week later they did
it
i mean japan's the one country where you
probably wouldn't mind a machine eating
your money yeah yeah
you know you're getting that back yeah
you're gonna have a bag so yeah that was
a that was a thing so since then but now
i'm married with kids and i'm an adult
now
gosh terrifying proper adult what's that
what's that like
i gotta ask though because you came to
japan like at a
obviously much earlier than that because
for us coming to japan you know there's
plenty of resources for us to like learn
about what japan life is like
you know we have like a lot of way more
vloggers and more youtube videos and
more resources that we can look at
but what was it like for you was it
almost like coming in blind like what
was you
what was it like coming to japan back
then compared to
how it is now i mean the first time i
came well i'm sorry the
time i moved here i had already been
here about
six or seven times either doing um
mostly doing work or like what i said
before like i go on holiday and
you know so i had a lot of friends uh
you know
make friends with people who speak
english and stuff you know i'd have
flaws to sleep on and
yeah contacts and things like that which
you know with japanese people they're
very friendly like if
you know you can impose on a japanese
person terribly for like two or three
days
and they're kind of hat they're they
don't mind it's like yeah you're gonna
only gonna be a couple of days that's
fine yeah right
so i had a pretty good idea of what i
was getting into
at that point and i knew i'd have like i
sort of set myself up with people okay
i want to buy a car i want somewhere to
stay i want i need all this sort of
stuff
and i kind of worked out how to do it so
it wasn't really that bad and i knew
like you know i bought a kick-ass laptop
we've got internet um when i first
arrived and i was staying at my friend's
house
uh you know they had internet there i'm
like oh what so what's the is there like
a download limit i don't want it
i don't want to like i don't want to get
throttled like what's a download live
i love this country every
no it does yeah yeah it does too and i
couldn't believe it i was like what do
you mean you only get three gigabytes a
month
yeah that's ridiculous i use like like
20 gigabytes a day minimum
yeah for like youtube and netflix
nowadays how how do you
do that it's a criminal man it's
criminal man i i wonder like how is
because i feel like when i've asked uh
japanese people who've been you know who
are like 30 40 plus
you know how japan was back then they're
like oh not much has changed but i think
because they've been living here they
don't see it that way
i wonder like as someone who came here
in 2005 how is japan like different
than from now like majorly is there
anything that's changed like
the biggest thing i mean there's been
quite a few changes in the past year
honestly
yeah yeah pretty obviously you guys but
uh the
as a as from a foreigners point of view
accessibility to everything is just it's
just wide open now
yeah you want to you want to know how to
get to random little
place google yeah that's it and there's
there's pictures of what it looks like
it's just so easy like no matter where
you want to go it's it's much easier now
whereas back then
you know like for example going to
akihabara you'd find some random
uh you know guy's blog that he'd like he
was like
obsessed a bit because the problem was
like back then people would flavor
their content with their own tastes yeah
this guy was obsessed with finding like
laserdiscs
yeah right certain things and laserdiscs
and um porn
i mean one of them's been phased out the
other one hasn't been the other one has
exploded in popularity
the so the uh you know it would tell you
all these places to go and he had like
you know where all the at like all the
anime studios are like yeah he's gynax
he's whatever it's like if you want to
go they had a map of
where they were it wasn't it wasn't a
map it was just like explosion like it
was like a literally
um directions from the closest station
like walk to this corner and turn left
it's creepy yeah it was it was weird
but i mean it's it's you just how it is
yeah just find things like i've still
got the first notebook of like my first
trip there's a lot of like printed out
maps and handwritten notes and things
like that
how do you navigate a handwritten map of
our cowboy like it looking through
google maps is already confusing yeah
just you just walk down the street and
just hope for the best well that's
well i mean it's it but it's it's it's
so no matter where you turn it's like
there's something yeah yeah and
even if you want to look i i've sort of
found about japan is
you focus on one thing and then see what
you find along the way
because you'd always find these random
like i mean all the best stuff is like
oh this is what's this random floor oh
it's like some dojinshi shop and you
find like oh wow there's all this cool
stuff here like that's yeah yeah
so you didn't really need it back then
was there any foreigners back then like
in japan because
there isn't that many now but i imagine
it was even less back then
so for akihabara the biggest notice the
biggest difference between then and now
is uh there's less video games and more
the claw machines
yeah okay uh the the billboards
are more blatantly
how do i put it say what it is
like a lot of titties and [ __ ] yeah
a lot a lot a lot of loot stuff yeah a
lot of losers
nowadays definitely uh like the boundary
has gotten
further it's more like like bam although
although
on the other hand though the uh like the
um the error gear shops
are not like right out in front anymore
like they're all underground
yeah back then like like on the on the
front the front of the edge shop that
have like the big wall with like each of
the games and a little ticket
yeah so you just you on the street
you're like i want
oh i love this yeah something sister
something
you go inside and buy it whereas now
it's more sort of all shut up
yeah yeah it's more like tourist
friendly like they still have like the
maids and stuff also yeah the maid stuff
like that didn't that was
none of that back then oh really was it
yeah like originally
i mean there were but now it's like
every corner that's like the new made
one
yeah like there was the big ones but
there's not all like the the little
niche ones like like the ninja ones
[Music]
yeah yeah i think i watched a
documentary yesterday of an akihabara
that was like 2005. it was horribly
edited
right it was like a horror show i mean
that's that's what every anime
documentary was like back yeah yeah
i don't even know what it was supposed
to be though like it was i couldn't
figure it out but there were
they had there was like made they were
showing some maid cafes around but it
looked like
very early on yeah like i think like the
sketch i think that was
around the time it happened because they
were following the author of higurashi
oh and his family oh wow that was really
weird because
in this documentary for some reason i
know this is going on tangent which made
me laugh my ass off there because this
super serious documentary and the guy
with higurashi he had his whole family
helping him make it and then his dad was
in charge of research
and his dad dead ass to the camera goes
yes i had to study how much gas it would
take to blow up a classroom for one of
his novels and
i was like i was like what he decided
that like
he said it like it was nothing like how
much gas to block how did you find that
out like what resources is there
it's the difference between a large
explosion and a small fire
but did you really have to find out how
much gas there was could you not have
made up some arbitrary amount of gas
who was going to read higashi like fact
check it's like
oh i don't believe that's the right
amount of gas to blow this classroom
yeah i mean come on like if modern day
america hadn't happened yet come on
you want to be factually correct in in
like how to [ __ ] kill bodies right
how did this
weird like tangent but that was just
about the documentary 2005.
it was a it was slightly different
you know even even more of the old uh
the old electronic stuff was still
there still is now but it would that was
i thought that was cool like that was
the main stuff though right yeah
like you turn down some random alley and
it's all like blade runner electronics
and stuff
yeah oh wow that's really cool because
my dad like when he first came to japan
it was like in the
like the mid 90s like like kind of early
to mid 90s like before i was born
um and like back then akihabara was
called electric city yeah yeah
nowadays it's there's barely any of that
[ __ ] anymore right like the electronics
shops and everything are like all behind
like in alleyways or
yeah there's like the big anime shops
that you actually go in the first
level yeah yeah that's where all the
electronic stuff is right yeah
because like you go you go out you go
out the uh train and you see like the
electric town exit
yeah the electric tower i remember my
first time coming i was like why is that
why is it called electric town
exit well what has this got to do with
electricity
as eventually that's eventually going to
be just be like the anime town
i guarantee going back to drifting i i'm
curious because
obviously normal youtubers they have
this kind of
i buy the camera i buy the [ __ ] that's
it i probably have to spend much more
money unless you're mr beast of course
yeah but i mean is it is it hard running
a youtube channel where
it requires you to buy a bunch of
[ __ ] cars and
tires all the time how much a year do
you spend on tires alone ah
it can depend on the year but i mean one
depending on the car
like one one tire can go between
say or fourth like 40 or
40 to 120 dollars per tire depending on
how good it is so let's just let's say
like seven or eighty dollars a tire
so that's two yeah and a regular track
they're probably gonna go through
four if not more depending on how crazy
it goes i see you upload sometimes
sometimes weekly but it was more like
kind of over sporadically over a month
right like yeah and is that every single
time you're making a video you're
probably doing that
no well uh okay so you i could these
days i think i could
yeah right for various reasons because
the uh the the market
for people to watch those sort of videos
is much bigger that's huge
like every everyone watches youtube now
like everyone yeah it's a thing that's
the only place you can get that sort of
content too like you can't really
get it on tv because it's not on tv or
anything like that so
right now is a really good there's a
good lane for automotive content right
now
uh but the most cost effective content
is
going to a meeting or some sort of cool
event
like a festival
you just drive there walk around going
hey guys look at this cool stuff and
uh the best thing about that is like if
i know what i'm talking about
uh
that's another thing that made me
confident you want to explain what that
whole thing is oh okay what's anita okay
so most a lot of the audience is gonna
will know what these are
but so itasha is those uh the anime
waifu cars
yeah that are like you know wrapped with
like some character or some theme or
whatever
the ones that always get upvoted on your
reddit or pop up in your feed every once
in a while
right yeah you see them like it'll be
like wow i've never seen any of these
before
yeah you come to japan and there's
entire festivals for it oh yeah
uh so what itasha means is so in japan
when they refer to a car
like uh an american car you can say it's
an amish
ferrari or whatever yeah but they
changed the character for
like italic the katakana to the kanji
for
pain so itasha literally means
pain car because i mean as i explained
in the video when you you look at it
a normal person looks at and goes
[Laughter]
so basically it's it's literally more
like cringe cars it's a crazy
uh but the people who drive those sorts
of things they just don't care they're
like super hard correct yeah this is my
waifu and i love her
and there's there's not much bigger of a
flex than like how to represent your
waifu
slap it all over your car and drive
around and all right that's like the
next stage from just wearing like a
t-shirt with your glasses twice with the
glasses done right yeah exactly yeah
yeah absolutely it's uh
you know yeah it's the step up it's the
t-shirt then it's like the what do you
call the the armor like the badges where
they have all the full
oh yeah right and then it's like up from
you know you have this then it's a
plushie and then it's a figurine and
then it's a car
a car and a lot of the cars too have you
know they put the like the nestle
betty's in there and stuff like that on
the dashboard yeah yeah
yeah so um so some of the most popular
content i've done
on on twitch and also on youtube was
this itasha show
yeah that they run every year in tokyo
uh down in odaiba
uh they didn't run it this year
unfortunately obviously
everything's canceled this year
unfortunately yeah but uh so
what so when i made that video this was
before i
knew there was such a big crossover in
audience
between anime between cars like it's
sort of like the japan
anime cars there's a big there's
actually a big crossover in the middle
there right
uh so and even people are like maybe not
necessarily
into cars like like people who watch
initial d they'll enjoy it because it's
a cool story it's action whatever yeah
you know so there's all this sort of
stuff too so i went to the show i
thought okay how am i going to
cover this show i don't want to be like
full on weeb
hey guys look at this look at this you
know look at this big city anime girl
34th edition anime girl from that one
manga panel that you all know
i know like i didn't want to come across
two i wanted to do you want to alienate
my car audience yeah i still wanted to
you can say it you didn't want to come
off as crazy that's pretty much like i
want to hide my power levels
i walked around the show talking about i
know i know about the car and this is
the character like i explained like okay
this is like this show
uh it's about this sort of thing
whatever yeah this is
this show is yeah it's a bunch of you
know magical girls and they all die
horribly it's really good well so i've
heard i i don't know i haven't watched
myself i've just heard things
and i'm making jokes too like oh you
know i wonder what these guys
girlfriends think if they go pick them
up from the train station these cars
oh wait who am i kidding ha ha ha like
sort of like trying to
meanwhile yeah you're like god i wish
that was me
you're 100 right and some people
actually took big offense to like
oh man show some more respect towards
these things man it's like don't
you under like you should be able to
understand i'm actually it's clearly an
inside joke right
yeah so anyway so that that got really
popular and all of a sudden i realized
oh i've got this audience and then
you know next time that show ran i did a
live stream on twitch
right and it's probably one of the best
maybe not the biggest numbers i've ever
done
but probably the most engagement i've
ever done right i blew out my data for
that down but no we're gonna keep going
i covered this whole show it was really
good i actually talked to
um uh tv there was a tv uh crew there
and you know they i was they talked to
me and i didn't actually make it on the
show i think because they asked like
so you know what the people overseas
think of these cars and japanese tv
wants the you know the nice response oh
yes they're very wonderful
yeah i basically sort of said like
because i was on the live stream and i
didn't want my audience to think i was
trying to be fake or something
yeah a lot of them say like there's a
lot of like really young girls on the
cars and they think that's kind of weird
[Laughter]
i mean what do you want to say there's
like you know cameraman
yeah all that tv is hyper positive here
yeah yeah yeah yeah so i don't say bad
things i didn't really care
especially japanese i was meaning for my
for the
dude it's a different beast when there's
a twitch chat on you because it turns
you into like the meme
yeah yeah because you don't want it you
don't want twitter turns into the worst
person but yeah that's the same thing
with the crunchyroll anime awards i
didn't want to be cringed so i was like
[ __ ] twitch tracks watching me what
would twitch what would twitch chat
respond to
just troll just say dumb [ __ ] yeah with
love so they can go like pog no way
yeah because i remember i because that a
video of yours i think was from like
2017 or something it was a long time ago
it's like two or three years at least
and
i i like when i heard that you were
going to come onto the show i was like
okay i gotta you know obviously do some
research yeah on the guest
and i found that it's a show video i'm
like why does this video look so
familiar and i remember i watched that
video i think like
maybe like two or three days after it
came out because i i don't know if you
remember but like that video initially
was
getting recommended yeah everything
because i watched that video as well
back then oh really yeah yeah
it was it was what you're trying to say
is algorithm he knew you before you
i knew you were before you would be yeah
but it was cool as well because like i
obviously
very like knew very quickly that like as
you were kind of
explaining the different shows and
whatnot i could very clearly be like oh
yeah this guy knows this [ __ ]
but he clearly just doesn't want to like
show it all he's like
like i've been a closet wii before i
recognize my fellow brethren
you know what i mean coming from being
an old school we
what is your opinion of like the modern
anime scene in modern anime cultures oh
man
okay um so i think so
this is the interesting thing is when i
moved here right you'd think like oh now
i have unlimited access to all this
stuff i'm gonna i can just do it now
i actually didn't actually end up
quitting
you know what you know what i quit on
well the last thing i actually sat down
and watched like i'm gonna sit down and
watch this was the k
on movie wow
that's such a [ __ ] throwback oh my
god [ __ ]
why i don't know but just i watched that
and i'm like
i would quit anime watch okay okay
question did you like the kl movie
no i didn't did you like taeyeon though
i liked chaos okay okay
okay something nice about the thought of
someone in the cinema watching k
on and then thinking i'm done with anime
now
for me i don't know if it was maybe it's
just like that's enough
or yeah maybe it was a combination of
like well now i'm in japan it's like all
this stuff that you see
doesn't feel as like unique in it yeah
well it's like it's there it's it's
it's not as romanticized anymore right
i don't know if i read it somewhere or
someone's told me this but when you come
to japan
you realize that manga artists are
actually they're not creative they're
just
really good at representing real life in
a very consumable way
right that's true yeah and and that's
not a bad thing obviously that's great
like you you
you get that's really good about reading
like
the sort of like the daily life genre
like chaos like
like like yatsuba like all those sorts
of things it's
all the stuff you see in those is real
life just sort of compressed into like a
a form where you can
consume it all really quick and i think
that's that's a great thing that
makes it really enjoyable to read or
watch or whatever
but i just sort of like yeah that'll
that'll do and
unfortunately that was also at the peak
of what is
was i guess was known as like the moy
blog yeah yeah yeah
and it just kind of ended up i don't
know it just sort of turned me off like
yeah
i don't know yeah as much as as much as
i love the moe blobby or
like kind of halfway through it i was
like all right can we get something else
now i i hated the mo
blobbier i remember like i so the reason
i haven't watched fullmetal alchemist
was because
that was during the moe blob the era and
that was when i thought i needed to save
shows in case i lost my faith in anime
because there were there wasn't enough
shows coming out per season to like keep
my interests
yeah yeah yeah yeah and then the east
coast era started i'm like
okay boys i'm good the what the isakaya
so now we're
i don't want to i don't want to see a
bunch of normal teenagers
in like some fantasy you know i i get it
it's
it's cool but it's it's it's not it's
it's it's not it's not cool
as someone who likes the east coast i
can definitely say like most of it is
[ __ ] trash it's not self-aware enough
it's like yeah it's it's basically like
an rpg game but it's real it's like
all of you would get annihilated the
first time you faced an enemy
[Music]
all these characters and stuff what's
the original um there's a one called
escaflonade you know that one yeah yeah
i guess that's like an original sort of
that was that was
an isakai before the real the modern
escape formula
really started i think because it was
like it was like you were dragged into
this world
and it was all this crazy [ __ ] yeah
whereas now it's more like
yeah this is us yay and it's just like i
don't know that just turned me off even
more
yeah i'd say like uh gun and i covered
this when we did the
we when we did an issac animation list
but and uh now and they're here and now
are probably the two shows from like the
90s that like really kind of built the
foundations
i said there's in usher as well as well
and then dot hack came along yeah kind
of like put in the whole like video game
aspect yeah
this guy thing and then and now we're
here and it's just
because i feel like east kai back then
it was all about you get transported to
this world but it was always about
finding your way back home yeah because
it was always like
it was always a desolate kind of rough
world to be in but now it's all about
man
i like this place i want to get hit by a
truck so i get
i get transported to another world and
there's so many [ __ ] shows where it's
a teenage boy
who's a [ __ ] in cell then he turns up
and eight girls want to [ __ ] him
and then it's never mentioned that he
came from another world ever again
unless it's
kind of convenient for why other people
want to [ __ ] him yeah i'm so
bored of this [ __ ] man can i get
something else please
yeah he needs to say it i'm kind of
bored with uh
other one i don't know this is kind of
controversial or not but the the genre
of
where okay how do i explain this where
you have
it's like a harem anime but the main
character is not
male they're a female they're female
but it's like they're basically a male
but for the for the convenience of the
story they're female like what's the
what's the dragon one
uh dragon one the the uh with um
with uh you're talking about are you
talking about stuff like oran high
school no no
no no the one with what's that character
and the other and the other one
oh yeah like the main character is a
female but it's
it's actually male if you think about it
like it's like it's like the position of
a male right
right yeah it's like no no no no she's
female
she's okay with the vsauce
she's a female
am i missing something no no no no
there's other ones there's other ones
like that too where it's kind of like
yeah the main character is female but
it's
it's it's it's an analog of a male but
it's female so it's okay it's just like
uh it's just even worse
i don't know yeah i i get i get the
genre you're talking about i'm just
trying to think of like other ones that
kind of fit into that
i can't remember the name of them but
it's this other ones too where it's kind
of like that it's like
it's cool so you didn't like dragon maid
no i didn't like really
it's just kind of two on the edge of
like of like
it's not it's not actually lewd guys
[Laughter]
not gonna lie if he was a toss-up
between watching anime and just
[ __ ] tearing a car to shreds on a
track yeah
yeah that's probably gonna be my hobby
like i mean
i think the only difference is uh
there's a six dollar a month
subscription and like a thirty thousand
dollar problem
how much is it does it cost to drift on
a yearly basis for you man
it can it can it can vary but you throw
in the profits if i had to throw out a
budget like okay you're gonna need this
much to a year to drift
uh car fuel insurance
registration maintenance and
the occasional like you're gonna stuff
it into a wall
yeah yeah and you're gonna break a bunch
of [ __ ]
ah at minimum maybe at minimum maybe
like thirty thousand
dollars if you want to drift maybe
maybe once a month or once every couple
of months at like one track day
i mean needless to say the kids don't
get good christmas presents
no i'm kidding
you're like daddy's got you something
special she's a [ __ ] up tire
just buy them and use our tires and like
are you gonna use that
if you can't use that daddy can use that
you know some premium oil for you here
children
have you ever thought about getting an
itasha yourself yes
oh really what would you what would you
get what would you
okay i turned 40 years old this year so
i don't know how i i really don't know
see
there's two ways you can do this there's
the one way we can just be shameless and
like this is my waifu
but there's the other way like because a
lot of western people
are very like timid when it comes to the
itasca like it'll be like
dragon ball or yeah like it's something
where it's not like
yourself no no no no it's no no it's not
whereas here it's like some
studio leaf you know visual novels
yeah yeah like this is what i fapped to
like
that's it so i guess if i was going to
do it i'd have to go i'd have to go
hard in and go like okay yeah who's your
wife i just don't know i don't have any
these days i mean i thought
who was you who was the og waifu for you
like the one that you first was like yes
this is my waifu ah
a long time ago i really liked lam from
udacity
that's the og one yeah you can't get
more og than love i'm pretty sure she
was like one of the first
white foods she was the one that would
ever exist dude like the eyeshadow and
the and the
bikini i have no idea what this
character is oh really you've probably
seen her she's the one with like
the green hair and like the tiger tiger
bikini i've seen it yeah yeah yeah
there's like those horns yeah
i've seen that i just got this great
image of you like
like rocking up to your kids scoring
like an idol master card i'm just like
picking on your kids like come on kids
get in like that
man i got in trouble uh because like the
pr i just drive a van now it's like a
regular looking sort of van
but the van i had
okay so drift people the thing is
stickers
right like i guess it's sort of i mean a
lot of you know things do that too but
like
you know you meet someone here's my
sticker here's your sticker yeah yeah
i've got a huge collection
i've done like sticker sorting streams
on twitch and like three of them
wow so it took like six hours i guess to
do them all um so i i put them on the
rear
door like the gate of the car on the
back when you know whatever i'm sorry
and uh i did that my previous van which
i sold a while ago
and unfortunately one of them i stuck on
i didn't read what it said
it was written in japanese it was an
australian uh drift team because
they put like random [ __ ] on there yeah
and it said uh
what did it say it said
something like that like oh my god can
you translate that first tell him
elementary school kids are awesome
i don't know i don't know i
i guess it was like some they were
trying to be edgy or something because
it was like one of those sort of okay so
a lot of this is the one country
where you shouldn't have a sticker like
that yes a lot of anime
a lot of uh again this crossover thing
there's a lot of these like
sort of anime style slap stickers that
they make like they have like some
random anime titties and like some team
name or whatever yeah
and they've done this and i didn't check
what it said because again they came to
mbc circuit like a lot of foreigners
come to msu circuit they stuck it on
there
and i didn't read it and then and then
my wife saw it
he's like what the [ __ ] is this
and i'm like what she has this sticker
here i'm like
yeah and i'm like i i didn't want to
peel it off because it was stuck on the
paint because it probably would have
peeled the paint off so yeah i got like
a black marker
i want to get it off the media but i
don't want to ruin the car well yes
i didn't want to now i vet my stickers
before i put them on
probably i probably should have done
through a screening process i have like
a [ __ ] irrational fear of stickers
i have no idea i really the thought of
stickers you know how like people used
to
when you're in school people just put
stickers on each other yeah they used to
be disgusted people did it too why
it's like no i don't know just [ __ ]
freak me out they're putting stickers on
me i'm like that's disgusting get that
off me
i hate stickers they are like the worst
thing ever magnets i'm cool with no
problem
stickers gross i don't know why is it
like the stickiness of it i think it's
the stickiness the sound i'm like that's
disgusting get that away don't get that
away from me
the sound the stickers make i [ __ ]
you know you don't put any stickers on
any of your products or anything i
thought on my laptop
it was a gift and i felt bad not to but
a part of me it pained me so [ __ ]
really
that's like going in front of an
audience being like this is my weakness
i also have a weakness of money uh i
can't stand people putting money in my
pockets so if you want to
sorry it's called it's called patreon
i can't stand it connor you're like the
one you're like the one guy who's like
most
into cars then now you can't be a
drifter now because you don't like
stickers
do they put oh that would piss me off
stickers is the main thing if someone
came up and put a sticker on my car like
what have you done oh people
ruined my car people do that okay so my
i have at nbc circuit i have a skyline
that i actually i leave it there like
it's my
car that i drive when i go there and
i've told people like on you know hey if
you if you come to ebisu
just put a sticker on my [ __ ] that would
drive me up the wall i don't
[ __ ] touch my car that's just how you
make friends that's how you bond it is
like the stickers is not consent
i'll stick your card if you stick my
card bring your plastic sheet right now
right put the sticker on that the moment
[ __ ] rip that off
it's a tourist attraction like they send
me selfies like drift car like
yeah yeah because it's sort of like i
guess sort of semi-internet fighter i've
never been so horrified in my life
oh you can't be a drift driver then if
you don't listen [ __ ]
after i did the drifting i was like
telling the boys i was like you know
what i actually think i'd get into this
it's pretty fun but first you have to
get over your irrational fear of
stickers
i want to put that aside you know what
the worst thing is like so when you when
you buy
tires and because you know drifters
usually they fit their own tires then
you save money uh tires have a big
sticker on them it's so like
the brand you have to peel that off
peel it off and i can do that i can get
rid of them
hey people who put stickers on things uh
okay it looks so tacky as well it does i
agree [ __ ] hate it
i i agree but it's like it's sort of
like a you know who you know
like you know if it's a badge it's just
like it's
almost like a laptop disgusts me when i
see it where is
this this man has so many [ __ ]
stickers on it it drives me insane
oh jesus christ that's pretty normal
it's like someone's spreading their ass
cheeks in front of me i'm like get out
of here
it gives me all the memories i remember
when i got all of these stickers that's
it yeah you you
you know like on on my channel i go to a
workshop and they're all like oh can we
put one on there
it's like i've been here i know these
people like yeah and i'm just a guy
who's just been never
i've never been given stickers or
anything like that i don't know do you
have to memory
sometimes yeah because i've never been a
guy to be like i see a sticker this is
this is what i need this is my memory
because
it's always the budget item it's always
the the pity item
whatever it's always the t-shirts or
anything i guess we have stuff because
there's a there's a there's a sticker
shop actually in uh harajuku called
b-side label that i go to quite often
where it's like it's it's these like
really like
some of those stickers on there are from
there and it's just i don't know it's
like really cool designs like but then
again
i was always like huge into stickers
when i was a kid like i was that one kid
who had like
books and books i can tell joey okay
joey has this off-camera obsession with
what he calls peelies
right like so so whenever when exposed
so every time we get some some new kind
of furniture or contraption
to have like the plastic the plastic
feelings right you understand it right
it's like you have to go to another
piece
people who like it and then there's joey
you're like i swear to god he [ __ ]
has a tenth of an orgasm every time he
does a single peeler he's just like
just kick can can i can i do it and he
just he just does it slowly
i'm just like yo joey do you want me to
leave you alone for like five minutes
man like
dude it's i [ __ ] love it you
understand right especially when it's
like the clear stuff not that it's like
when it's that dark blue one
new phones i like it because you can
alright no no you can't go faster
you gotta go slow slow you gotta you
gotta tease it you gotta tease it you
know
it's gonna make like that look at that
glossy surface underneath
yeah exactly see alexa gets me i get it
yeah yeah
you guys is this is some australian
things that we just don't get
to do in australia and also when you're
a kid right
people would always like when you went
to the hospital or the dentist they'd
always give you a [ __ ] sticker
and when i was like yeah i love that
when i was like six i was like bold of
you to assume i want this [ __ ] thing
on me
don't you [ __ ] dare get i think i
have the exact same
fear of like irrational fear but not
with stickers but with like buttons and
badges
i don't like those i don't like badges
what do you mean oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah the the the pin badges because i
didn't get stickers i would get like
those pin badges and i'm like
don't you [ __ ] put that on me so you
[ __ ] touch me
yeah i was never into the pin badges
because like if you collect a lot of
them they just make way too much [ __ ]
yeah
like i never yeah i never understand
people who go to like anime conventions
and they'd like
buy the pin badges of like if you're
gonna buy any anime
memorability why the pin badges anything
else perpendicular japan [ __ ] loves
pin badges i don't know what it is
like every every single like you'll find
like a new anime series right and you're
like okay i'm
looking forward to when they're released
merch of this and they're like all right
we've released merch of it
have a pin badge bro it's like i don't
[ __ ] want it there's like detergent
of like it'll be like a [ __ ] evas ava
slash
detergent like cross [ __ ] yeah uh
promotion
and it'll have like it's got a it's got
a sticker of eva in it and it's like
people go [ __ ] nuts
oh yeah yeah what's wrong with you what
i mean i'm one of those who was like
hell yeah it's like
the the holy trinity of just useless
anime merchandise is stickers
pin badges and clear files clear files
are the [ __ ] words
no one needs this many clear phones yeah
i mean i i have a clear file full of
clear files so
i can't say anything but uh i just can't
end up using them because you know they
say it
says clear file but they've always got
some stuff yeah you can't do that
it's the unclear phone it defeats the
purpose of a clear file
anyway we went on a massive tangent
there yeah
yeah so like you you talked about your
opinion of like the modern anime scene
so like
what are some of your favorite anime
because we i don't think we mentioned
that it's normie as hell but i mean i
always just enjoyed evangelion
like back then because i mean i'd say
it's less normally now than it is
i guess so but back then so in australia
uh you know i'd seen a lot of stuff but
then
it came out on tv on um sbs
which is like a public channel in
australia it's like where they like air
a lot of the international shows right
right yeah it's my you know their show
like there was um there was a guy called
des mangan who presented like you know
the the
cult movies and stuff and sometimes it'd
be anime and i was like
anime so tonight yeah yeah back then
whatever you could whatever you could
get you took it like
it'd be professionally subtitled be
really good and they would
show evangelion uh they had like an
anime block where they showed some stuff
for a while
and that was good because that came out
on tv so everyone had a shared
experience of it at that time
so you know what i mean like it that i
think it's very it's very important that
shared experience
when it comes to this sort of media i
think like it's mostly
about video games that sort of thing
like you know if you meet someone who's
played like
whatever final fantasy 7 it's like you
immediately have a huge thing in common
right yeah like what's your favorite
part yeah yeah we've all done the same
thing at the same time yeah and that was
probably the first time that like
mainstream anime was shown on tv
so you sort of discovered other people
who are into it too because they'd watch
it it was accessible
yeah so i guess that it had a bit of an
impact and it was very um
you know it was it wasn't the standard
monster of the week's show there's a lot
more to it and i'm not trying
to sound like it's super deep or
anything because it wasn't but it was
just um
really it solidified like it was
engaging right it was very engaging it
wasn't afraid to
to you know make something different
like a show that's a bit different
but at the same time used every trope
yeah you know combined like you know
what whatever
that's the weird thing about a lot of
anime it is the most tropey unique
shows that for some reason get the most
attention it's like
you look at it like someone will look at
him being like like ava for instance
right
someone will look at ava and being like
whoa i've never seen anything like this
at all
but at the same time it's the type of
show where another person will look at
it be like
this has every trope that i've ever seen
dude uh
one punch man yeah okay i i
my wait my cousin my cousin's kids
a few a couple of christmases ago when i
went back and they were talking they
started talking about oh yeah we watched
this thing one punch man it's really
cool
and i blew their minds by going
this is actually based on a little kids
tv show called anpanman
and this that character is based on like
the dragon ball character this one and
this it was actually voiced by the same
guy
you dropped the anime knowledge on there
i just i explained something
worldwide [ __ ] you [ __ ] scoot them
man okay so
everything you like is actually based on
something else
your life is a lie don't be happy that's
exactly i was i was aiming to destroy
them because
it was just destroying that destroying
them with facts and history see that's
what this is and and so you actually
like this you should actually like
but again it's a gateway thing if hey
anything gets people into it it's like
look i don't you who cares anymore like
oh you're a bunch of
normie fans what do you know it's like
no it you start somewhere
you go this far it's like the same thing
like you guys have done drifting
if you don't want to go any further it's
like well why would you like
if you don't understand enough that's
fine you enjoyed it it was like you got
you got your adrenaline hit and it was
some weird stuff you've never done
before
you have a new experience that yeah
you've done it's in japan like
you've done drifting in japan yeah like
that was um
i guess this is the thing that i have to
offer to other people and i always try
and
not force it on them but if i can at
some opportunity like for example
um when uh reckful and sodapoppin came
to japan for their
legendary stream on twitch uh their irl
stream
right i hunted them down and said you
have to come
and go drifting because team orange had
those
two of their drift cars at a diver which
is only about
very close and yeah less than an hour
from anywhere in tokyo
to uh to go drifting so because i know
them i hooked it up i said yeah come
here we'll meet here we'll take them
instead of drifting
they went out that night and did um ram
and ram cosplay on the streets so
i guess they had a good day you know
yeah yeah yeah other guys like um the
irl streamer jake and bake the japanese
stream like i i got him a ride in
um a d1 grand prix cars about maybe 1200
horsepower gtr
you know live streaming it to like
whatever it was like 20 000 12 000
whatever people
yeah right i love to if if i can just
present it to people
as like a because i honestly i think it
is a really good
part of japanese culture that is not
only fun
and relatable but you know i mean any
like you said like you know it because
of
fast uh it's not fast fast and furious
people are saying initial d
yeah and i think it's a it's a cool
thing that i like people to experience
and i
i think you're welcoming as well yeah
yeah they were really friendly to us
that they're
now apparently every community was like
it's like go ahead okay no because i was
gonna say i mean like you talked about
how to
you know getting people to experience
this for the first time i mean we've i'm
sure we've done that like introducing
our friends and everything into anime
where we can just like recommend the
show or something but i feel like it's
infinitely harder with drifting because
like as we've talked about the barrier
of entry is like
so high and i feel like it's it's one of
those hobbies where
no one just no one just casually drips
you can't just be a casual drifter
you're like you're like either in this
all the way
or like it's something you experienced
once and you know i would
love to go drifting more um it was a
[ __ ] hell of an experience
but at the same time it's like do i have
the time and the money to commit to this
and it's it's you know it's it's
something about catcher
he said he spent like what like 30k was
it
that's a minimum that's probably god's
like monthly allowance from catcher come
on
quick gotcha he was telling me on the
train here that he's like man
i i would go drifting i just have to
quit gacha
but it's so hard i i think one thing
that i really appreciate about your
channel in particular and
to anyone uh listening uh that whereas a
lot of
youtubers here who live in japan who are
foreign it feels like an outsider
looking in on a lot of the content and
what was really refreshing i think from
your videos what i
i got was that it was like you were in
it with them and then you knew all the
like all the big players in the scene
yeah it was really cool scene that i
suspect because i thought when i
first watched your videos it was going
to be like hey i'm here let's find out
what's going on i'm going to see what's
happening but you like saying hi to
everyone everyone knew you
it was so cool yeah really cool seeing
that like
you get a youtuber in japan who is
really deep in the scene to the point of
where you know
even the people in the japanese scene
would know you yeah it's really cool
seeing that that
mostly came from the fact that back in
the day when i was doing uh
journalist work you've been around so
long well it's like if if i want to get
access to cool stuff i have to
make friends make friends with people i
have to show them
you know i i would be serious any event
i would show up this is the thing about
this is the thing about
anything about japan especially is show
up obviously right now you can't really
do that
but if you want to be in something show
up talk to people
get to know people i mean i've been on
i've been on tours of um
like a couple of anime studios because
i'm friends with someone else who knows
someone else and you just
you know because you know someone and oh
lexi's into that stuff why don't we go
you want to come too we're doing
something and
it's just knowing people and yeah
eventually guess it gets to a tipping
point where it's like you show up
oh yeah there's alexia and that's why my
friends
told me like when i first got here it's
like um
it's very difficult for a japanese
person to get to know and trust a
foreigner because they just assume that
you're not going to be here you know
yeah yeah or so and like another person
told me too like
lexi you have to keep going to track
days again and like all the time because
if you don't they're just people just
gonna forget about you
straight away so i do make an effort to
even if i don't
even driving like oh i got today off
i'll go to the track
maybe i'll make i'll take my equipment
with me maybe if there's something cool
to make a video but otherwise i'll just
hang around talk to people
and you know walk through the pits and
everyone morning
and then eventually they'll come to you
mm-hmm
oh i actually oh and they'll you know
they'll have something cool like and
someone will be like
oh are you driving today oh no i'm just
i just turned up it's like oh you want
to take my car out for a couple of laps
like hell yeah
i got my helmet in the van i'll bring my
helmet with me just in case
maybe go take a shirt off like the whole
kid
got my race just
show up and and do it and it gets like
that after a while i mean i've been here
12 years so
and i've been coming here for longer
than that too so yeah yeah i think that
kind of applies with any social security
absolutely all right it's like it's just
you know it's about commitment right
like you just got to if you want to be
known
in that circle or you want to be part of
that circle whatever that circle might
be or whatever that niche might be like
if you don't make an effort to want to
actually show
you know your commitment to it or want
to be like part of it then
you're not going to get in right yeah so
i mean like i was going to say like it's
the same thing with like you know with
like the anime industry as well like
once you know a couple of people
it's such a small industry that your
face just gets known everywhere as long
as you're staying committed to it like
that's really the only reason why like
any of us have like just like our friend
nabi
in like a nutshell right exactly he just
seems to know everyone and
when i ask him it's just he just says oh
you know i just know a guy who knows a
guy
i've just been around enough yeah i just
make my make you know go around and just
make myself
known yeah like that's so but the thing
is that's like so much easier said than
done
yeah you know because it is a lot of
commitment and it does take time and you
know
it's not guaranteed either that you're
going to get rid of no it's it's just
you got you just got to
build up recognition everything
everything because i i uh
it was interesting you mentioned the
point that people in japan just assume
people
are going to be living here like
unpermanently
like it like because having lived abroad
in like few different countries you know
there's like you make some expat friends
sometimes
right who you are you can be like the
closest friends with them
for like a few years but then eventually
they're going to move back
and it's really hard building like
building up a friendship from zero again
when you know sometimes that people
aren't gonna be here in like two or
three years
yeah i've definitely noticed that that i
even i made some friends when i just
moved here and i'm like oh cool i'm
making friends and then they left
i was like damn finally started getting
a good list of friends going and they
all just [ __ ] left
yeah can you imagine they had their own
problems
how dare they your
destiny the audacity to have
nationalities apart aside from the place
i'm living right at this moment i i have
to ask because you've seen our drift
special
who was the best drifter you and why was
it me thank you thank you
i mean was that really the question you
needed to ask there i want to just make
i should
you might as well just ask the question
alexis can you just give me a hand job
yeah you just want to whip your dick
right out
right now it's ready it's okay i already
got his paypal email so
i switched in the 20. now i look like no
okay okay i must admit even though
we clowned on you in the episode you
clearly were the best drifter you just
[ __ ] up in there yeah i just found it
up in the end i mean that touches
[ __ ]
because you clearly won the election
well you were the most sort of confident
with it so you got a bit too hectic with
it yeah that's why
yeah i would like to argue though that
the starting position was a little
different you know like like you you
were clearly
almost i mean you were the most excited
you're the most experienced driver
driving out of like i said before it's
it you all got to like i watched the
video and i thought oh yeah that's about
right like from what i've seen
it wasn't really different like if you
haven't you know the prerequisite for
learning how to
you know maybe learn how to ski the
prerequisite is being able to stand up
like yeah
yeah if you can't stand up then you're
not gonna be able to do it like so if
you're not used to
oh you know drifting uh to driving a
manual car for such a long time
also those cars have a clutch which is
kind of
that clutch was weird yeah yeah well
they're designed was it making it like a
rattling sandwich
yeah yeah and also i i feel like a
normal clutch like
if i touch it a slight bit i feel it in
the car yeah this one i had to [ __ ]
slam it down
anything out of it so i mean the
clutches in those because you know
you're constantly
slipping on them so yeah so the the
clutches are made to take a lot of heat
and also makes sense so yeah they're not
easy to drive
so they're definitely not easy to drive
yeah the car looks fairly
didn't look too extreme yeah they're
kind of a pain in the ass
look even i do that i i left my my mark
ii at the uh tuna shop like last week
and he let me like his drift car
like one of his personal drift cars just
as the courtesy car right
right what this he's like yeah i got too
many of them just take that one i've got
two minions
too much in the way and i stalled it
twice before leaving the car park and
he's like
he's like alex you suck i'm like yeah
whatever man
because everyone knows like it's always
hard to jump into someone else's car
yeah yeah i'm just like only two damn
i stole like eight times trying to move
forward yeah it was all right
yeah you weren't good it was it was i
think you'd be able to drive a normal
manual car because
even for me i like i stored it a lot and
i've like
i i've gotten used to it but like the
biting point is like so small
and it feels like you're gonna break the
car right as well right and you go like
one millimeter above and it just stalls
right like there's there's no leeway at
all
yeah they're a little bit tricky but
yeah and you all did pretty good it was
it was an enjoyable video and
uh even i enjoyed watching the whole
thing oh my god yeah that's good
that's a w i wonder how cause we
obviously didn't get to go on the the
serious track or anything right
how do you transition from just doing
your little [ __ ] donuts to like
actually going on a track like because
there has to be something like how do
you is there like a test
how do you in between that because how
do you learn because it seems like there
wasn't really a way
like it was it's just a slow progression
of um
like there is a little bit of a sort of
a wax on wax off approach to it where
it's like
you do the donuts right did you do those
you did the handbrake turn like the
parking
yeah but then what you do is you do the
handbrake turn
but then you transition to doing a donut
then that's a drift
right you didn't get to that point
that's okay yeah okay normally it takes
people a bit longer if you haven't
done any sort of car stuff before like
like that so it's just a slow
progression like you start off
going slower then you build a bit of
speed then you get a bit too
overconfident you spin out a lot
then you start to okay let's dial it
back a bit and it's just it's just
slowly slowly building up
it's kind of like what i've noticed is
so i used to play video games like a
quake
arena and stuff like that like boomer
stuff sort of thing back in the day
and you know but then i gave it up for a
long time never played shooters and then
all this whole the whole br thing
started beginning and i thought oh this
is actually cool like a lot of people
you're paying real people whatever
it wasn't like ces i didn't really get
into that and i started
i noticed that like you know watching
people you know pros playing again
is that they just sort of jump in it's
like first game is a dub it's like yeah
yeah
because they've just been doing it for
so long yeah whereas i noticed like if i
get in it's like the first two or three
games it's like yeah my aim's off i'm
terrible
yeah yeah same thing with drifting you
start off it's like
you got to like recalibrate everything
and it
just gets better and better and the
better you get the faster you can
hit corners really well compared to when
you're a beginner like it might take you
until the end of the day
you finally get that corner right i
entered at a good speed the car
didn't go too sideways i kept my speed
up yeah and you get that huge rush and
then you
get that again and again and again again
yeah and honestly it
doesn't the rush doesn't get any worse
like it doesn't get any lower
you just you just end up going faster
more angle you know more
more speed power power the orgasm just
gets more intense
it does i've solved you're really
selling me on this so like okay how
how long would you would you say it
takes to from like coming from nothing
to going on like one of the tracks that
isn't like the practice track
i mean you can do it straight away like
they have other tracks which are kind of
smaller
right but i mean i'd say i've i've been
drifting
uh let's see for like 20 years um
goddamn
and i'm pretty confident like i could
probably i've never actually driven like
a top level car before
i'm pretty confident that if you give me
a few laps i'd be okay at it like i'm
not a top level driver i've got the
i hold the second highest i've got like
a like a
diamond license sort of right
for a long time but i can confidently
drive pretty much any track that's been
20 years
if you it depends on you but if you
drifted every if you drifted
two or three times a week like say say
you go to every suit you went there two
or three times a week
it would maybe take you two weeks or so
to be pretty confident most of the
tracks depending if you crashed or not
right okay yeah like yeah the crash is
definitely yeah yeah
crashes are uh they [ __ ] people's heads
right when they like i seem like they're
mental towards like drifting if they
crash
some people some people i've seen people
quit drifting yeah yeah i've seen people
yeah it's like they'll like
they'll blow their engine or they'll
crash and they're like i'm done yeah i'm
done
yeah yeah like i've seen one guy
actually sell his car at the track
to some to another guy like a guy who
had a truck there with an empty truck
he's like
you want to you want to what do you want
to do with this do you want me to tow
you back to where he's like man i just
want to sell it
so the guy was it was a deal it was a
car deal he's like yeah buy his cash
casual vote for me
okay yeah that's about rage quit
so yeah people just give up because like
it's a it's a huge like
once you crash a car then it's it's a
big like decision
yeah yeah it's like it can cost like
several thousand dollars even to get it
back to
and it's it's a crashed car now it's not
perfect anymore yeah
it's not good you might from that crash
you might have all sorts of things
happen
so yeah be really expensive some crashes
you can be lucky it's just a bumper
other ones it's like you bend the whole
frame and the whole car is a write-off
and it's just parts now jesus yeah
yeah so it sounds like a double-edged
sword right like you can't
it's a gamble it's a it is a gamble like
i have um i've recently
set up a uh a simulator rig which i'm
hoping to use more on my twitch streams
uh
just to get more sort of seat virtual
seat time like it's not as good as the
real thing
right right but it's still pretty good
like it just you have like the steering
wheel like
yeah i got the steering wheel all the
pedals the
little seat and the rack and everything
yeah it goes on yeah yeah it's good uh
it it's it's it's at a stage now where
you can use it as a fairly good
facsimile of the real thing
not not so much as the feeling but just
the um
concentration mindset like a combination
of movements yeah like you can practice
your like because you know that like
there's
your tracks irl and there's tracks
in-game so i can watch the video of me
at the track and then go in the
simulator and go
okay i keep doing this here i've got to
unlearn that because then you just hit
the reset button back just back to start
back to start
you know screw it up okay back to start
let's try it again okay got it and you
just get that muscle memory that's the
future isn't it yes
i mean it's kind of like if you think
it's like a sort of a it's like a speed
run
if you think about it you know all
drifting in future will be done
virtually
drifting speed there are entire virtual
drift
i've seen i've seen yeah drifting
competitions and they're serious man
yeah i went in the comp once i just went
in sort of as a joke and i just made a
huge ass out of myself i crashed off the
start line
it was yeah it's serious and how do the
virtual ones compare to actually doing
the real thing though
in in the sense of what they do in there
it's like almost the same
oh wow like the way the way they drive
uh i mean even like there's things like
eye racing and stuff where it's like
it's a full-on nascar race and it's run
at like the same sort of schedule as the
real thing
right but it's just not real see here's
the thing here's the thing though
some some drivers who are really good in
the game
have tried doing an irl and they're just
like i can't do it it's just too it's
too scary
oh yeah a lot more forces yeah like the
g-forces yeah
also the fact that if you you could die
yeah yeah yeah
you could crash and get hurt like at
every like i said before like
i saw a guy come off the track hit the
wall like at an oblique angle
was it okay huh was he okay he broke his
uh he broke his leg and his ribs
yikes i'd rather that than a [ __ ]
sticker on my card
that do not peel off as well there's my
[ __ ] nightmare like industrial glue
stickers don't [ __ ] come sorry
are we still
that was like half an hour ago and
you're like you never forget recurring
nightmares
you'll just forget my feel like are you
kidding me man
oh my god so how often do you stream on
twitch oh god don't ask my subs that
they're very angry
i used to do a lot more regularly but
then like when um when the rona happened
i thought like everyone else did
oh this free time yeah i can i can get
back into it properly
no yeah that never happened it just made
it even worse
um my aim is like twice a week i want to
do some more like sim stuff also irl my
my next goal
is to do a full track day as an irl
stream now what's
your twitch i've sort of what's that
what is your tweet it is unfortunately
it's norriero japan
check him out check him out add that on
the end there but uh yeah it's uh
it's mostly car related stuff uh like
either
either car games like my summer car or
other sort of
indie games and stuff like that but i
also want to do more irl stuff
uh now that all this sort of stuff has
started calming down yeah track days are
running again
i want to get like a you know the
backpack all that sort of stuff and do a
full track thing i can't do really well
yeah that'd be something
all of my if you look at if you sort my
highlights like all the biggest
highlights are
all like around the car drifting so
the best thing about that is like it's
you don't know what's going to happen
yeah yeah i can crash in every corner
they're all
they're all waiting but then sometimes
something really cool happens like
i think i was in a car actually with
sunaga the guy you rode with yeah
right at ebay soup i was riding
passenger and he got like within a
millimeter of the car in front we're
doing like fourth gear
and chad is just going nuts
and then was he just like laughing like
he always does yeah
[Laughter]
just his laugh is just so like
emotionless and yet
yeah i was like what the [ __ ] is
happening it was insane
the man was in this yeah because i'm
absolutely legend i remember
i remember when we were like learning
the handbrake turns and just like that
one session gave me like the [ __ ]
worst wankers cramp i've ever like
felt in my life
i've never heard of this
because it's the same kind of movement
right god god
unfortunately where is your dick
like jesus no because i've never had to
i've never had to crank it like
that hard and it just it just was a
movement that my arms
weren't used to man what can i say oh my
god but it was it was fun as hell
that's a normal thing though you do get
also you you hurt your hand right
yeah let me tell you okay never never
put your thumbs inside the steering
wheel
yeah that's i think that's exactly what
i think i think he was scared to death
so he was gripping there no no
i i guarantee you that's what happened
is because what you do is you put your
hand your thumb inside the steering
wheel yeah and then when it counter
steers
yeah the spoke of it comes around and
wangs you on the on the on the finger
yeah yeah
that happens a lot that's exactly yeah
because that's exactly like now that i'm
thinking about it like if i was holding
it like this
where i injured myself is exactly where
that spoke was yeah it's a really good
they should have told you that
it's come on i mean
i i didn't think we were going fast
enough for it to [ __ ] matter to grip
onto that thing i was like
you know like yeah well sorry that
you're a [ __ ] man we're going slow
you didn't have to hold on i've never
driven a manual give me a [ __ ] word
where do you think the car was gonna go
joey
not a [ __ ] no i'm scared
anyway bullying you yeah anyway so uh
yeah it's been lovely to have you on
um thank you very much shout out
anything on your end uh well i
have a youtube channel norie aero uh
it's uh it's car stuff i do want to do
more um
if there's more itasha shows and i
eventually want to do an ether show as
well
you got to come out yeah we gotta wait
oh yeah yeah
actually i would love to see anita show
like like yeah enough
such a festival yeah yeah yeah 100 let
you know also
so this weekend i'm going out to a track
out in the middle of the mountains in
gunma which is actually uh
it's actually an old-school cycling
track it's like a mountain road sort of
thing but it's actually a drip they use
it for drifting now so
rip cyclists yeah it's going to be a
like a sort of simulated togay drifting
and all these cool guys
how many cyclists can we drift into
that's gonna be that's pretty cool and
i've got a bunch of other stuff coming
up i don't know so yeah check it out
also also social links
by the way um i bought a little present
i see have a lot of uh
things on the walls here so i brought a
little
oh little 86 from uh
it's even got the tofu thing yes oh
that's like cute
thank you very much thank you that's so
cute i love it
look at all these beautiful patrons yeah
yeah thank you and uh thank you very
much to the patrons for supporting us
and also supporting the drift episode
that we did
uh it's it's all lit up to here
and and also like we've talked about
this from like uh our perspective but if
you ever get the chance to try out
drifting even if it's just
being driven around a track i highly
recommend it as we've said
it is an adrenaline rush like you've
never felt before these guys have just
turned [ __ ] three right now i don't
wanna do it
but yeah if you'd like to support the
show make sure to go over to our patreon
also
check us out on our subreddit and our
twitter and if you want to listen to the
show on audio then check us out on
spotify yes
links on this beautiful boy yes
absolutely go check out all the links to
noriara stuff down in the description
below and thanks for coming on thank you
very much for having me
great it's been hope you've had a good
time yeah awesome and
uh with that said that's everything for
today we will see you guys next time
bye bye
[Music]
you